哈喽 大家好 欢迎来到这一期的文化有限 我是星光。
我是超哥 我是大一。
大家好 今天是21号 再过两天也就是4月23号。
又迎来了一年一度的世界读书日。
我想对于所有喜欢读书的朋友来说 423是我们共同的节日。
那这个月的17号到30号 艾波波克发起了世界读书日专题策划。
以重读为主题 邀请大家一起回顾以往读过印象深刻的书。
以及因为阅读带来的体验和影响。
欢迎大家在艾波波克关注收听和参与这个专题策划活动。
也可以在小红书互动发帖 分享你年少时读过的好书。
有哪个作家或者作品让你记忆深刻。
尤其是那些陪伴你成长 带给过你独特触动的阅读故事。
记得带话题词 艾波波克世界读书日。
重读一夜青春和我的私人苏丹。
那说到今天我们要读的这部作品是一本经典科普著作。
在出版之后很快就成为了畅销书。
在十几年的时间里也给很多读者留下了非常深刻的记忆。
我相信有不少朋友应该都已经读过了。
所以在临近423读书日的今天。
我们再一次一起重读来自丹尼尔卡尼曼的《思考快语慢》
这本书其实已经非常有名了。
它里面很多理论 概念 机制 原理。
都被不同的人在不同的场合拿出来讲过很多遍。
所以大家应该也非常熟悉今天我们阅读的这本书里面的很多理论和概念。
但是我们今天特别的把这本书从头到尾的读一遍。
我们三个人也是根据之前读科普作品的方式分章节。
对这里面重要的以及有意思的一些概念进行了书里和总结。
如果你也读过这本《思考快语慢》
也对这本书有自己的非常多的理解。
或者是在现实生活当中。
你把这本书里面提到的很多概念理论和方法。
也运用到了自己的实际生活中。
你也可以在评论区给我们留言说说你的感想。
说说这本书对你的启发。
我们会从评论区选出五位朋友。
送上纸质书版的《思考快语慢》
欢迎大家的留言
说到这本书其实我们说科普书籍。
尤其是跟人类的大脑怎么运行的有关的科普书籍。
每次读的时候
我的感受就是除了刷新自己的认知之外。
就觉得自己的脑子不是自己的脑子。
就觉得感觉自己已经不是自己的主人了。
以前总觉得我们是理性的。
我们可以通过自己的思考。
来控制自己的想法和行为。
但是每当读这样的书。
包括我们前面读的《贪婪的多巴胺》
还有今天的《思考快语慢》
这样的书的时候
我们就会发现好像自己对大脑的控制力。
和对自己身体的控制力完全不是那么回事。
控制不了一点
没有主体性了
我根本没有主体性。
对 没错
这个时候我们就会有一个疑问。
说那我们知道了这些理论。
知道这些方法以及运行的机制之后。
我们该怎么办呢？
我们该怎么克服掉那些我们不想让它发生的事。
比如说一些错误的判断。
一些认知的偏差
以及行为上一些我们不愿意出现的事情。
我们怎么办
这些书里面其实也有提到。
针对这些情况
我们可以采取哪些办法。
这就又成了我们人生工具箱里面的工具。
增加了这些工具之后。
我们就有可能在需要用到它的时候。
拿出来应用它
首先我们就请大老师。
给我们介绍介绍这本书的主要内容。
它到底是怎么讲的。
讲了人的大脑里面哪个部分的事。
哪些部分的机制
这本书最早是11年初的英文版。
然后12年就很快引进了中文版。
所以这本书也得有十几年了。
非常著名唱销热销的一本书。
那这个作者刚才情况也介绍了。
丹尼尔·卡尼曼也是诺奖得主。
但不是文学奖的得主。
是经济学奖的得主。
很多人认为它是行为经济学之父。
这个行为经济学
其实我觉得过去几年。
大家可能已经是一个比较熟悉的概念了。
在各种各样的平台上。
我们可能看到很多对于行为经济学的解释。
但是这个词最早是怎么来的。
其实它并不是一个很经典的概念。
它只是在卡尼曼它的研究过程当中。
它提出来
因为它并不是一个完全研究经济学出身的人。
它是一个心理学研究者。
它是一个心理学的有很多学历的这么一个老师。
所以它是把心理学的很多内容。
引入到了对经济学的研究里面。
所以才有了行为经济学。
就是跟传统的经典的经济学有一些对照。
一会我会再讲这个区别是什么？
然后这本书思考快与慢。
卡尼曼提出了一个理论。
就是说我们的大脑。
人类大脑看起来是一个脑子。
但是其实是有俩系统在同时运行的。
系统一和系统二
它这个命名也非常的简单直给。
就是一和二
看完这本书
我感觉所谓的这个快与慢。
它有点像是直觉和思考。
就是思考里面到底哪部分调动的是我们的直觉。
哪部分调动的是我们大脑。
正在思索的本来的深度的东西。
所以系统一按照卡尼曼的定义。
是自主运行的无意识的快思考。
擅长直觉联想和一些情感反应。
系统二
它是需要你付出一些努力。
才能调动起来的
具有逻辑性的慢思考。
负责一些比较复杂的计算。
字控
这两个系统各自有他们的优劣。
系统一虽然比较高效直接。
但是它是容易产生系统性的偏见的。
书里面后边它也通过各种实验。
经济学的各种謬误去告诉我们。
有哪些偏见是我们通过系统一。
自己得到而不自知的。
系统二它虽然理性。
但是它非常耗能
它举了一个例子
比如说现在大家正在听我们节目。
你会觉得这三个人声音怎么样。
这是一个三人的播客。
这个其实都是系统一在自主运行的。
但是我突然问你
直觉17乘124等于多少。
这个时候很多人就卡住了。
因为这个问题它调动的是你系统二。
比较理性
比较耗能的算力
会有这么一个按他的说法。
就是生性懒惰
所以我们的大脑经常采用系统一的直觉结论。
没有用上系统二
好 那怎么办
这本书通过五个大部分来分析。
解释这套系统是怎么运行的。
首先第一部分就是这套系统是什么？
我刚才就大概说了。
然后第二部分就是告诉我们说。
为什么人类大脑在面对统计学。
这些事实表现的时候。
老师笑
会表现得那么差劲。
为什么我们对数字。
不像对外界环境那么的敏感。
对概率经常会有些误判。
然后这里面其中一部分叫做起发法和偏见。
这个所谓起发法
看起来比较陌生
但我觉得简单理解。
不知道对不对
就是一种经验主义。
就是一种不受控的经验主义。
想到一个例子
比如说咱们都看中文。
有时候会遇到不认识的字。
读错别字的时候
所谓的有边读边
我感觉就是起发法的体现。
就是当我们的系统一。
这个直觉系统
面对了一个回答不了的问题的时候。
这个系统一会自动的找到一个相关的。
更容易回答的问题。
这个过程叫做起发。
然后你得到了一个新的。
起发性的问题
来替代原来的问题。
就产生了一种心理上的洁境。
其实你并没有回答那个真问题。
而是不自觉的替换了。
起发了一个新问题出来。
然后这种起发法
会带来很多的偏见和谬误。
所以它所谓的起发跟我们说。
我突然得到了某种起发。
那种积极性的起发不太一样。
它更像是一种控制不了的生发。
发散
扩散出来的一个东西。
然后这本书里面它又举了一个例子。
就说本来的一个目标问题。
本来我想问
我现在应该买这支股票吗？
听起来是一个非常理性的。
经济上面的投资问题。
做决策的过税
但是我们其实人的大脑。
是很难直接回答这个问题的。
然后我们的系统一就会接管思考过程。
系统一会说
偷粮换柱
把这个问题换成了说。
那我喜欢这家公司的产品吗？
它可能会给你替换一个新问题出来。
然后你不自觉的说。
我喜欢这个产品
但是你会得出一个说。
那我应该买这支股票。
但是我们再从系统二号。
理性分析的时候
这俩没关系其实
对
你从一个喜欢产品。
就得出这家公司
未来的业绩表现会好。
其实这个关联性是比较弱的。
如果你真的想获得一个股票上的资讯的话。
你的判断标准应该是更复杂的。
更麻烦的一些计算。
所以大脑通过回答这样的问题。
通过这样的启发
直接给出了前者的答案。
那这本书的第二部分。
就是要拆解这个过程。
就是告诉我们说
在我们大脑有意识的这个过程当中。
思考到底发生了什么改变。
他做了哪些偷粮换柱的事。
让我们对他有意识。
这是第二部分
然后第三部分叫做过度自信。
因为有了前面的
首先介绍了这个硬胶系统。
就是这么个水平了。
就是这俩系统
然后其次就是这样的系统。
会产生这样认知的偏见也好。
叫bug也好
这是前两部分
第三部分就是讲说。
好 那在这样的运作偏差下。
既然直觉这么的不靠谱。
就是系统一
这么经常容易出错误。
为什么我们还有那么多专家 学者。
KOL觉得自己非常的准。
那我们会怎么认识这个世界。
我们试图拿捏这个世界。
预测未来走向这件事。
是多么的不靠谱
但是又无法抗拒
这种自信是怎么来的。
所以第三部分叫过度自信。
然后作者提到了两个重要的概念。
一个叫后键之名
一个叫有效性错觉。
这个一会让超哥展开讲一讲。
好 第四部分叫做选择。
这一部分是我看的最累的一部分。
我相信很多朋友看到这真的是皱眉头。
就是它疯狂调用系统二。
各种实验 各种概率。
我甚至都想拿根比算一算。
这到底是怎么回事。
你也不行
我以为就是因为我是学文的算不过来。
我看得这个很痛苦。
现在学文的数学也好得也多的是。
跟学文学历已经没有关系了。
没关系
那主要是我不行
对 纯个人
你平时系统二训练的不够。
咱们这方面肌肉都差点。
所以里边有大量的数学统计学的实验。
反正挺费脑子
它讲的是什么？
就是面对这种不确定性。
人以为自己做了什么选择。
然后人其实做了什么选择。
还有人本来应该做什么选择。
就是他把这三个东西给你拆开来看。
然后这个就涉及到刚才说。
卡尼万老师
他不是一个诺奖的经济学得主吗？
他的当时获得诺贝尔经济学奖的。
一个核心理论就叫做前景理论。
第四章
其实主要是在讲前景理论这件事。
就靠这章获得诺奖。
所以你看得累
那肯定的
就是你后来你也知道。
就是诺奖水平的东西。
咱看着累也非常正常。
对吧？
你看不懂得应该的。
我不知道能不能这么总结。
如果说错了
咱只证
就是前景理论是讲说。
是一个解释人类在怎么不确定的情况下。
来做决策的这么一个理论。
然后这个前景理论的意思就是说。
未来的发展
比如说跟说一个职业是不是有前景。
跟一个选择是不是有前景。
这是一个与境抽象出来的。
一种可能性的方案。
所谓的前景
更像是一个选择或者一场堵住。
所以他的核心观点是说。
人在做选择的时候。
并不是总在计算
我未来能获得多少。
我能赚多少钱
我能获得什么样的好处。
而是在想相对于现在。
我的前景
我的未来
通过刚才我的选择到底是亏了还是赚了。
就是亏和赚这件事情。
比我真正实际赚多少。
那个绝对数字
更能击中我们人的内心的直觉。
所以在这个过程里面。
就有两个特别关键的特点。
一个是人对损失特别敏感。
叫损失厌恶
另外一个就是
人对风险的态度是会改变的。
双标
对 就是一个不断双标的过程。
那在传统经济学
或者刚才我说的古典经济学里面。
我们有一种假设
就是人都是理性动。
对吧？
人都是理性人
诸大一个理性人的概念。
那理性人的认为
这个核心是什么？
就是人的行为逻辑是通过。
效用最大化来决定的。
就是什么样的决策。
会让我的收益最高。
我去干什么？
这个偏号是一致的。
那唯一的驱动力
就是个人效用最大化。
那人是不应该受到情感。
冲动或者认知偏号的影响的。
但是坎尼曼提出来说。
原来的传统经济学的解释方案。
可能是有问题
就是
但很早就把这种心理学的动策。
集成到经济学里面。
我们可以理解说
刚才前面说的行为经济学。
就是坎尼曼的这本书的主要的理论。
他就是对古典经济学里面理性人。
这个假设的一次修正。
好 那整个修正法。
他的观点就是说
人的计算能力是有限的。
就是我们这个大脑。
就是你能想的事就这么多。
而且你集中运算一会。
你这脑就荡机了
很容易感受到这个认知疲劳。
然后你的决策依据也不总是一致的。
你会被这种启发法。
这种直觉或者就是系统一的影响。
你会产生什么损失厌恶。
恐惧 贪婪等等这些情绪。
他都会影响你做出那个决策。
像什么我们经常提到的。
刚才损失厌恶
或者说锚定效应
这个都是在第四章里面提到的主要概念。
都是坎尼曼在认知心理学和行为经济学里面。
提出来的非常厉害。
现在我们可能已经非常熟悉了。
比如说你谈判的时候。
有一个什么锚定效应。
然后我们在做很多决策。
或者是收入的时候。
你会有随时厌恶的情感。
但是最早这个概念。
可能都是坎尼曼比较早的提出来的。
很厉害
这会让我们重新理解。
我们所谓人在经济社会里面的各种决策。
然后我们到底是怎么运转这个世界的。
好 这是第四部分。
然后最后一部分
第五部分叫做两个自我。
这部分就比较好理解了。
前面四个部分说
我们怎么是做思考和选择。
第五个部分讲的是。
我们怎么感受到幸福。
一个看起来比较虚的事。
但是幸福的评价体系也是可以建立的。
在幸福的评价体系里面。
也会有两个自我
一个叫做体验自我。
一个叫做记忆自我。
体验自我是更关注当下的。
有点像系统一吧？
可能体验自我是关注当下现在的感觉。
记忆自我是对过去的回忆。
那我们在做决策的时候。
或者说我问你们俩。
最近幸不幸福的时候。
其实你脑子里面调用的是记忆自我。
往往是凭借记忆自我在做决策。
但是这里也存在着一些误导。
第五章会讲这是怎么回事。
最终
凯尼曼提出了一个人生大灾问。
就是说我们到底是为谁而活。
我们为哪个自我而活。
不是为你爸你妈
就是当说体验自我和记忆自我的时候。
我们到底是活哪个自我。
这就是整本书的五个部分。
超哥
刚大老师说记忆自我。
我想起来一个例子。
给大家形象的带入一下。
就是刻瓜子
我们老说刻瓜子
不管你之前刻得多开心。
只要刻最后一刻是坏的。
你就之前觉得太难受了。
这一次唱刻瓜子
都让他给毁了
对
这个体验自我和记忆自我。
就是如同刚才我说的一个刻瓜子的事。
我们就是这样被操控的。
对
然后我再补充两点。
就是思考快语曼这本书。
虽然凯尼曼拿的是经济。
但是我们不能认为它是一个经济学家。
它其实是一个心理学家。
它之所以拿经济学奖。
是因为它在经济学理论当中。
提出了一个所谓的理性人假设的。
这个理论的质疑
或者说新的理解方式。
所以它拿到了经济学奖。
但它依旧是一个心理学家。
所以我们也不能把这本书。
看成是一本经济学的著作。
它其实是一本心理学的科普著作。
然后这本书出版之后。
就很快成为了唱销书。
尤其是在棒球球探和高管当中。
我做功课的时候发现说有广泛的追随者。
是因为这两种职业的人。
他们都是那种需要根据有限的信息。
去做特别重大的判断的职业。
比如说我去一个球探。
我是不是要把这个人招募进我的球队。
那我掌握的信息一定是有限的。
但是是不是招募这个人进来。
我得在他身上花好几千万。
这个是一个非常重大的判断。
还有高管也是
说我这个公司下一步要做什么产品。
做什么决策进行哪些战略方向的选择。
这些都是在有限信息的条件下。
做重大判断
因此他们这些人对卡尼曼的这套理论。
其实是比较欣赏并且愿意去信服的。
然后他们会觉得
对卡尼曼说的特别对。
用这个来指导自己的行为。
指导自己的生活
那接下来我们请超哥。
给我们介绍一下
丹尼尔卡尼曼和他的研究。
前面说了丹尼尔卡尼曼。
他不是一个资深的经济学家。
他自己是这么说的。
他说我虽然获得了诺贝尔经济学奖。
可是我觉得我自己获得这个奖。
像是拿了邻居奖杯的人。
但是我从来没上过一节经济学课。
我对经济学的了解。
几乎都来自我的合作者阿墨斯。
他这里边
我们书里边的很多实验和研究。
都是和他特别好的搭档。
阿墨斯一起完成的。
开启这个研究的时候。
他们俩是同事
可是很不幸
阿墨斯在1996年的时候就去世了。
诺贝尔经济学奖
是不会搬给已经去世的人的。
所以丹尼尼曼就自己独享了这个奖项。
所以他在很多的场合也会说。
说如果我的搭档在这的时候。
我们俩应该是共同分享这个奖项的。
而且我们知道思考跨语曼这个书。
其实不是靠着这本书获得了诺奖。
大佬前面说
他只是里边的第四部分。
那一部分的理论
前景理论
对
对他获得诺奖有重大的意义。
他是2002年获得了诺奖。
然后这本书是2012年初的。
所以这本书可以视为。
是对他之前的所有研究的一个综合。
他是一个极大成的书。
因此也就知道他为什么？
这么受欢迎或者这么畅销。
一个诺奖的获奖者。
他人生前半部分所有的研究。
成果 理论
以及他是怎么研究都在这本书里了。
所以这就是大家都想看看。
他都是研究了啥 咋研究的。
所以这本书就很畅销。
然后接下来给大家稍微讲讲。
他为什么开始做这项研究。
就很有意思
就是他一开始做这项研究。
始发于他和阿墨斯两个人的。
一个特别偶然的观察。
他就会发现
因为他们俩都是做心理学研究的。
心理学里边就会
应用到大量的和统计学相关的知识。
然后他就会发现
他的同行 包括他的学生。
我们都是受过这么专业的。
统计学专业的训练。
按道理说应该很有逻辑。
为什么大家在做很多研究成果的时候。
还是会被很多非常不理性的。
非常具有小样本量的事件所误导。
为什么我们还会做这些。
看似非常不理性的。
不专业的发言
为什么我们怎么这么难自控。
所以他就说
那我们一起去研究研究。
这些人的决策是怎么做出来的。
然后他俩就开始往下研究。
就压根不是说咱们做一东西。
咱们去获得Norbert经济学奖。
完全没有这个
不那讲去的
对 完全是借由自己身边的一个小事。
就是向彪老师说的。
把自己作为方法
然后就开始研究
这是一件事
第二件事就是
卡尼曼在特别年轻的时候。
他受雇于以色列的军坊。
来做一个工作
这个工作就是有点像招聘HR。
就说帮我们筛选这些新兵。
出入营的时候
帮我们筛选新兵
我们要做一个判断。
看看我们今年这些新兵。
哪些他的未来职业发展。
会有什么样的前景。
就是做一些前景去的沾望和预测。
这个预测就包括
比如说我们通过一系列的问卷。
看看他更适合去哪个兵种。
他是适合当这个兵种。
还是去步兵
还是去研究导弹
通过面试
他未来几年
他的会不会发展很好。
他就想弄套模型来预测。
结果他会发现说
我已经尽全力
把这个问卷弄得非常详实了。
结果会发现我们这个研究。
和人家后边真正的职业发展。
没有任何关系
这个预测很差
他就想知道说
到底出了什么问题。
为什么？
这跟我们很常见
比如说我们在做HR招聘的时候。
我们倾向于问一些问题。
你对这个事怎么看。
然后包括做一些性格评估。
会发现这个人是个情绪稳定的。
什么浙纳的
现在高考报支院是不是也这样。
好像还不一样
因为高考报支院
你就是填报你没有预测。
他这个相当于对人做一个评估。
有点像那个SBTI。
16型人格
就是你个新人面试。
或者我们以前很多企业有管陪生。
这是个新人
我们来看说这个人要不要着重培养。
如果通过我们测试发现。
哇 这个人老有潜力的。
那我们肯定在他身上砸大钱。
好好培养
让他成为企业未来的支柱。
包括很多这个奖学金也会这样。
临选的过程当中
然后他会发现
我把这个问卷问得已经非常详实了。
用过去的方法和手段。
各种的判断
然后我们在做跟随的时候。
你会发现这个人未来的职业生长。
和我们之前的判断差距非常大。
不仅是差距大
几乎可以说是毫无关系。
他就想说
那到底是我们这个预测出了什么事情。
出了什么问题
所以他就开始研究。
所以大老师说那个前景理论。
前景理论就一部分就是。
当我们在信息很少的情况下。
要来进行预测
那我们怎么进行预测。
他就是希望说通过这个研究。
是不是能给这上述的问题。
带来一些答案
然后就开始了研究。
然后研究完之后
大家一听就是一个纯心理的。
纯自己本学科领域内的研究。
怎么就去了经济学领域了。
这在中间有一个小插曲。
就他们俩把这个研究报告。
没有发在心理学领域的刊物上。
而是发在了一个经济学的刊物上。
为什么这样
因为他会发现
降为打击
他不是 他是这样的。
换个赛道
他的这套理论研究完之后。
就是发现我们人
不会像经济学家说的。
没有那么多的纯粹理性。
然后他就说
那我就要把这个研究报告。
发在号称自己最理性的人群里边。
这才能做到最真实的反应。
我发在理性人堆里看看。
对
结果发在这个刊物上特别有意思。
发现所有人就对他们的理论。
大多数人都是成批评态度。
就说你们这个不行。
研究肯定大家反响很大。
同时吃脂以鼻
可是嘴上吃脂以鼻。
身体很诚实
你会发现这个刊物。
他们发表的结论成为了当年。
或者是那一段时间。
被援引次数最多的文献。
用脚投票了
还是认可的
所以慢慢的
他们就变成了
经济学领域里边的一个。
很重要的发现者
或者很重要的研究者。
在后来
卡尼曼就是专注于。
这个叫行为经济学这个领域。
就是大老师前面不是讲说。
这个行为经济学和古典的经济学。
到底它是什么关系。
它有点类似于一个补充。
或者一个分支
因为经典的经济学理论。
它有一个前提假设。
就是人是个绝对的理性的经济人。
他把人看成一个经济人。
那经济人做决策
就不会受到任何情绪。
其他外界环境的干扰。
我做所有的决策
都基于一个非常重要的前提。
就是我个人的
效能和利益的最大化。
来进行判断的
可是做行为经济学的。
研究的前提
就是我们把人看成一个普通人。
我们不是那么理性。
我们没办法在那种。
特别完美或者是
绝对真空的条件之下。
做决策和判断的
因此我们的行为会发生什么呢？
然后他们来进行观察。
所以这两个理论之间。
它其实是一个互为补充。
可以理解成古典经济学。
它就是一个
完全的完美的理想的状态。
真空状态下的意思。
对 真空状态下的一个人。
是怎么做决策的
假设摩擦力为0
对 理想实验
这等于10
行为经济学
就说我们不能这么假设。
或者说我们把这些。
各种的条件都带进来。
带进来之后
看看人是怎么做判断的。
人是怎么做决策的。
人是怎么行动的
就大概是这个关系吧？
看尼玛现在被大家谈论。
更多的著作
是他有一个新的作品叫造声。
他其实也是
严习了这个行为经济学的这一脉。
就我们做决策的时候。
其实你的思想或者你的行动。
是受了很多外界环境里边。
给你植入的很多东西的影响。
你虽然没有察觉
但是其实这些已经前一末化的。
控制你的行动了
对 影响你的东西是那个造声。
对 大概这就是
卡尼曼的一些世纪。
我给大家稍微讲讲。
卡尼曼其实
他特别重要的地方。
就是在于
他发现了经济学里面的。
理性人的假设
但是他用他的研究理论。
挑战和补充了
这个现代经济理论当中。
这种人类理性假设。
因此他启发了很多经济学家。
对于他们自己的理论。
在发展的过程当中。
会让他们更加丰富。
更加多元
所以他拿到了那本经济学奖。
这是他的贡献
不是全盘否定
而是大家一起搭台的唱戏。
就把这个东西弄得更完整。
更丰富
对 因为我们今天读这本。
思考矿译办的时候。
我们也知道他里面提到了很多人类。
特别有的
我们看了之后也觉得。
还确实是这样的
很多认知偏差的现象。
他在这书里面也提到了。
他的目的并不是为了告诉你说。
你其实就是像这样。
有很多认知偏差
人类就是愚蠢
没有办法
没有意识的
做不到 控制不住自己。
他不是
他是说我们知道这些现象存在以后。
我们就可以想办法。
怎么样去尽量避免和规避这样的现象。
让这样的现象尽量少的影响。
我们真正重要的决策。
这个其实是他想要在这本书里面呈现的。
以及他在经济学理论里面也是。
经济学发现说
人可能不是像他们所想象的理想状态下。
那么理性
那怎么办
我们在这种不是那么理性的假设的前提下。
我们该怎么去把自己的经济学理论更丰富。
让它更完整
或者是别人知道这个武器。
它用在我身上的时候。
我得知道它对我使什么招了。
尤其是很多买家卖家之类的。
我们上网买东西
连粗销的行为里面很多这种。
是连某些画术和手段和计量。
对
节目一开头的时候。
我说我读这本书
感受感觉自己又一次失去了对自己大脑的控制。
就是大脑其实根本不在乎我们善不善长。
或者愿不愿意去做什么理性的思考。
它自己有自己那一套运行的方式。
包括前面我们读贪婪的多巴胺也是。
多巴胺也不在乎你到底是不是。
说我能不能控制你。
它也不受你控制
对吧？
那甚至于很多时候在这本书里面提到。
系统一起作用的时候。
是在你无意识的时候就已经。
已经做完了
就帮你做出了判断。
你自己都不知道
你就用系统一做出判断了。
是的
那这也就让我们不禁怀疑。
所谓的那个自由意志。
到底还是不是我们人类所能掌控的东西。
就发现读这个书
不仅失去了对大脑的控制。
还发现自己特别愚蠢。
总是会被脑子里面的这些。
运行的机制所控制。
不知不觉当中就做出了判断。
做出了行为
不建议把这本书和多巴胺那个书。
连起来看
不然的话就会产生巨大的自我厌气。
和自我幻灭
不不不就缺了
那你是早没遇上它。
早遇上你早缺了
而且它这书里面都是那些。
已经被科学研究证实的现象和理论体系。
所以它是被科学证实的。
你就是这么愚蠢
人类就是这么愚蠢。
你又没办法反驳它。
就这种很多你的认知偏见。
你的很多行为上的错误的原理。
都被它说中了
就这一点还是整个阅读的时候。
我的感受非常新鲜。
那接下来我们就进入这本书。
《分章节》的一个书里。
我先来书理一下第一部分。
第一部分其实是前面大佬也介绍了。
它是整本书的一个基础理论。
就是它上来就提出了。
人类的思维模式有两种。
一种是基于系统一的。
一种是基于系统二的。
系统一就是所谓的快思考。
系统二就是所谓的慢思考。
这跟这本书的题目也是一致的。
但是大家一定要注意。
它里面特别强调了。
所谓的快思考和慢思考。
系统一和系统二并不是在人的大脑当中。
真实存在的某一个部分。
或者是某一种器官。
它不是甚至也不是存在的。
某一种化学物质
它不像我们所了解的多巴岸一样。
多巴岸是真的存在于人的大脑中。
它的对神经地质的作用。
是真的是可以
刺激人的形成一种生理上的作用。
对但是系统一和系统二。
对人的影响不是从生理上来的。
你可以把它理解为一种人格化。
或思维方式
思维逻辑的体现
所以它把它总结成系统一和系统二。
我相信系统一和系统二在做决错的过程中。
一定有大量的生理性的过程。
以及大量的化学物质参与到这个里面。
但是它没有去细致的分析。
到底哪些化学物质起到了什么作用。
它只是把它统称为系统一和系统二。
我们看系统一前面说到了。
读这个书让自己感觉到特别愚蠢。
愚蠢到哪呢？
就是它里面提到了很多系统一。
会产生的认知偏差和误判。
比如说避害大于趋利的损失厌务。
大老师提到了
还有包括很多比如说归因偏差。
包括一致性效应
它里面命名了很多效应。
还有聚光灯效应
某定效应
光环效应
曝光效应
这些都是它给它的研究起的一些名字。
在插的这个书里面。
它对这些效应做了非常详尽的分析。
这些效应是怎么产生的。
以哪些科学研究的结论。
证实这些效应确确实是存在的。
然后它代表了什么？
如果你想要去了解这些效应。
会对我们做决策做判断。
我们的行为产生哪些影响。
它在这一书里面都有非常详尽的描述。
我就不坠述了
第一部分里面的两个系统。
它具体是怎么来论述的呢？
就是它用了两个非常经典的例子。
开篇就说明了这两个系统的区别。
一个就是它给了你一张图片。
这个图片是一个女士愤怒的脸。
大家看书都能看到。
它说人一旦看到这张脸。
你瞬间不需要任何判断。
你直觉上就知道这个人在生气。
你甚至能预测掉它接下来会说什么？
这是系统一起作用的毫不费力的快思考。
然后紧接着就是大老师提那个问题。
他再问你17×24得多少。
你就不能用这种非常直觉的。
非常快的思考得出答案。
你就要静下心来去想一想。
你可能在纸上还得写个。
曹搞运算一下
你才知道17×24的结果是什么？
这就是系统二暗部就班的慢思考。
那这两个系统
它说存在一种协作和冲突的关系。
首先是分工协作
系统一它属于人的思维方式里面默认的模式。
它统计大概人的日常决策当中。
有95%到96%的占比都是用系统一来做决策的。
那只有4%到5%才涉及到系统二的慢思考。
所以大部分时候我们都是用系统一来做决策的。
也就是我们所谓的默认模式。
缺省模式
然后系统二
系统二它的角色是监督者的角色。
有点像
系统一在做这些决策的时候。
系统二会去监督你做的角色对不对。
但它系统二通常会处于一种低能耗的模式。
就是有点像电脑当中的那种对桌面模式。
或者是锁屏模式
傻巴嘶嘶
你不动它
对
你不唤醒它
它就不会起作用
它仅仅在有必要的时候才会介入到整个人的思维模式的思考当中。
那系统一在94%到95%的占比决策的时候。
它像系统二不断的在输送信息。
这些信息就是提供给系统二印象。
直觉
印象
感觉
提供给系统二这些东西。
那系统二会进行一个什么样的工作呢？
就是认可
或者叫盖章
盖章认可之后
会转化成你的信念或行动。
这个是整个决策的过程。
但是我们这个时候就会发现。
这里面有冲突的点。
特别有意思的地方在于。
它在这个书里面给这个效应。
起名叫斯特鲁普效应。
就是当系统一所做的决策的那种默认状态下的自动反应。
和系统二想要取得的意图的任务目标冲突的时候。
当你调动系统二的时候。
就会非常的费力
要消耗你的注意力。
这就是斯特鲁普效应。
就是废脑子
对
说白了就是废脑子。
现在用AI时代的话说就是废脱克。
那它在里面做了一个小试验。
也是一个相当于脑筋击转弯射的东西。
就在一张纸上
用红色的墨水写不录。
然后它的目标是你要说出这个颜色是什么？
那正常来说这个颜色应该是红色。
但是它写的是不录。
写的是蓝
这个时候就造成了你大脑的思念模式的一个迷惑。
然后系统一因为它快思考。
所以它是用直觉的方式来做决策的。
那在这种情况下
它就会自动的去读取它那个词役。
因为你要用眼睛去看它那个词。
你看到是不录
你就自然而然的可能会说。
这是蓝色
但其实要你说的是红色。
那你怎么去要克服这种自动反应的冲动。
就需要让系统二去介入。
就要用系统二刻意的花一些更多的注意力和努力。
脑力来看
说原来这是红色墨水写的。
我应该说它是红色。
而不应该直接说它是蓝色。
这个就是它所谓的那种斯特鲁普效应。
这是两个系统互相冲突的那个节点。
然后紧接着就引出来了一个核心的问题。
就是我们说思考的懒惰。
其实指的就是系统二的懒惰。
而懒惰是每一个人的天性。
是每一个人的本能。
也是系统二的本能。
因为它天生就非常的懒。
它倾向于接受系统一的建议。
但是它有另外一个倾向是。
不太会做大幅的修改。
也就是你可以把它理解为。
大部分时候它是一个橡皮图章。
就是系统一做了直接的判断之后。
给你系统二监督一下。
系统二过来
改一图章
行了
同意
就过了
对
它也不太会去反复说。
你这个不行
然后吹毛球刺的去看你到底。
做出这个决策有没有道理。
它不会
基本上就是看一眼。
就过了
就是领导呗
我当时看到系统二的时候。
就觉得想起了那个网上的一个梗。
说是妇爱如山
为什么是如山
因为它不动
系统二就特别像
因为它懒惰
对
我们头脑当中一个父亲。
所以系统二它只有在确确实实。
必须启动和被唤醒的时候。
才会出来做决策说。
你这个不对
你得改
你不能这么干
它才能承当这样的角色。
越来越像妇爱了
是不是
或者说妈妈挤眼了说。
我不去
我去你去吧？
她才去
天生懒惰的系统二。
它在论述
人的认知资源有限。
特别容易疲劳
特别容易不集中注意力的时候。
它在这一段是这么写的。
然后分享里边的片段。
它说
在上述情境中
你必须集中注意力。
你如果没有做好准备。
或者注意力分散
就会表现欠家
或者根本没有办法执行任务。
通过对注意力和记忆。
自动功能的预设
系统二
可以改变系统一的运作方式。
比如说
在西西昂朗的火车站。
等待亲近的时候
你可以去刻意的寻找白发老太太。
或者留胡子的男人。
从而提高在远处发现亲戚的可能性。
他说
当你在伦敦西斯罗机场租车的时候。
地勤人员可能会提醒你。
车辆要靠左行驶
在这些例子中
你要做的都是一些。
没有办法自然而然去完成的事。
也就是没有办法
靠系统一
靠直觉去完成的事。
你会发现
保持设定的状态
需要付出持续的努力。
集中注意力
这一常用语说的是没错的。
你能够分配给活动的注意力。
是一笔有限的预算。
如果超出预算
你就会失败
对
这个我觉得
就是他在这里面论述。
系统二所需要的注意力资源。
是一种非常有限的资源。
人为什么老说
你要集中注意力干某一件事。
或者说你不能三心二意。
其实说的就是这个。
你如果三心二意
那你可能每件事都干不好。
因为你注意力分配不足的情况下。
系统二是没有办法。
非常好的完成它的任务的。
那接下来他又开始说。
说这就导致了一个。
非常惊人的事实
在于系统二
它不是一个富爱如山的。
懒惰的一个系统吗？
那当你以为你自己是深思熟虑的。
做出了某个决定的时候。
其实95%的这种决定和决策。
是由系统一完成的。
系统二只是在事后做了一个确认。
盖了一个章
所以这就是我读这个书的一个。
非常大的感受
那人类所谓的理性思考和自由意志。
是不是这件事就不存在了。
因为往往很多事情。
都是用你的系统一的直觉在做决策。
系统二只是事后做一个认可。
做一个盖章
那他又紧着说
控制注意力的能力。
不仅是衡量治理的一个标准。
有关注意力控制效率的测量结果。
还可以预测治理的测验。
跟智力测验形成一致的结果。
就是当我们发现一个人。
他控制自己注意力的能力。
特别强的时候
我们就可以认为
这个人的智力水平也不会太低。
这是一个相互相成的过程。
然后接下来就提到了。
一个关键理论原则。
就是系统一因为是靠直觉。
它是快思考
所以人特别喜欢干的一件事。
就是从现有有线的信息。
你看这就提到有线信息。
做决策的判断
从现有的信息里面。
构建起一个连贯的故事。
然后因此他就意识不到。
我所掌握的信息是有线的。
他就意识不到有可能。
我从有线信息里面。
所做的决策是不完整的。
是有问题的
他意识不到了
系统一已经非常好的享受到了。
我从有线的信息里面构建起的。
所谓连贯的故事
他更喜欢连贯
他不在乎说这个信息是不是完备。
所以他通过构建起这个连贯的故事。
也就是他里面提到的这个叫。
你所见到的就是一切这个原则。
系统一通过这个做了决策以后。
系统二就越不会质疑他。
这就有点像我们在听故事的时候。
人为什么是喜欢听故事的动物。
就是因为故事他有逻辑。
故事他连贯
当我们听一个连贯的故事的时候。
我们可能就不太在乎这个故事。
是不是真的了
我们就不太愿意去调动。
自己的系统二去问说。
这个故事里面的那个细节。
是不是真的
你得给我想清楚
那个细节是不是真的。
人不太愿意干这个事了。
因为这个故事太好听了。
这个故事太连贯了。
对
我们就不会在乎这个组成这个故事的信息。
是不是完整的了
最后他也提到了很多效应。
比如说启动效应
曝光效应
其中关于曝光效应。
我想给大家分享一段特别有代表性的。
他说
曝光效应并不依赖于有意识的熟悉感。
事实上他完全与意识无关。
即使重复的单词或图片一闪而过。
观察者从未意识到自己见过他们。
曝光效应也会发生。
出现次数较多的单词或图片。
最终仍会更受侵赖。
现在真相大白了
系统一会对系统二。
意识不到的事件印象做出反应。
事实上当人们完全没有意识到。
自己见过刺激物的时候。
曝光效应会更强
这就是什么？
当他们在做实验的时候。
他会突然出现大概0.5秒。
或者特别快的出现一个东西。
在人的眼前赏过
做完实验之后再问那个受试者。
受试者会发现
他对那个一闪而过的东西。
反而记忆的更深刻。
这就是所谓的曝光效应。
或者说人对重复的东西的喜好。
做广告不也是吗？
做广告洋洋洋洋洋。
重复很多次
就会在你的大脑中形成思想钢印。
我们就跟这个形成联动了。
所以说这种重复对人的喜好的影响。
是在曝光效应当中体现的非常重的。
然后他接下来还稍微解释了一下。
为什么？
他说重复对喜好的影响。
是非常重要的生物学事实。
适用于所有动物
就不只是人
为什么？
因为当动物处于一个。
自己熟悉的生存环境。
他见到的东西
都是重复在他眼前出现的时候。
他会自动的判断和认为。
这种生存环境是安全的。
因此他对这个东西更接受。
这是曝光效应的来源。
这是跟人的从原始时代。
走过来的一路的认知是有关系的。
那最后
这个第一部分通过两个系统的对比。
两个系统的配合
两个系统的冲突
以及两个系统分别的运行机制。
他讲了很多笑语
最后他说
人类并非我们所认为的理性的动物。
我们并非是偶尔犯错的。
而是系统性的可预测的犯错。
为什么？
因为系统一
在95%到96%的时候都做了决策。
因此如果他犯错
那就是系统性的犯错。
就是可预测的犯错。
第二就是人类的偏见是源于效率。
这个效率的意思
就是刚才说的曝光效应。
说我们对熟悉的事物觉得安全。
那是净化赋予人类的一个工具。
因为这种认知
我们人类才有更多的生存几率。
所以多少代
延续下来
我们有了这种曝光效应。
我们有了这种思维和思考的方式。
那最后他也提到了。
大佬说到了后面几张。
他重点起到的叫起发式判断。
这个起发式判断我也查了一下。
就是他翻译的可能不同。
大家如果对起发式这个数语。
如果觉得理解的不太好的话。
也可以理解成结净。
或者理解成触发
思想结净
对
当我们看到一个东西的时候。
我们就被他起发了。
被他触发了
然后大脑就形成了结净。
形成了连接
就把一个本身不应该联系在一起的两个东西。
联系在一起去思考了。
这就是系统一在起作用。
这就是快思考在起作用。
但就是起发式会导致很多认知偏差。
这个是他后面来详细论述的。
对
这就是第一部分的一个大概的理论基础。
它是整个这本书的后面的这几章节。
都基于这个理论基础。
再往下深入的去论述更多的理论。
那接下来我们就请超哥来给我们讲讲。
接下来在第二和第三部分当中。
丹尼·卡尼曼给我们讲了。
哪些特别有意思的概念和理论。
对
超哥
我在讲我这个第二和第三部分之前。
我先给大家讲一下。
这个一到五部分之间的关系。
就第一部分新光讲的。
它其实相当于是一个整个这本书的基础。
你说是什么？
因为它要讨论系统一和系统二。
所以他先把系统一和系统二是啥。
在第一章都讲明白。
然后后边这四章它的关系大概是这样。
第二和第三是讲这个系统一和系统二。
怎么在微观层面上影响个人的。
他就把这个个人从群体当中区隔开来。
他讲了很多例子
紧接着这个第四部分和第五部分。
它是个逐渐升维的过程。
四其实就把整个个体放在大环境当中。
你从这个比如生活场景中抽离出来。
把个人放在这个大环境或者一个组织里边。
会带来什么样的反应会发生什么？
然后第五就更宏观层面的。
探讨到幸福和人的终极意义层面上。
这个系统一和系统二是怎么影响我们。
它就是一节节逐个升维。
然后我再回过来讲这个第二部分。
第三部分它就是在新光第一部分的基础上。
讲完是什么？
接着就讲了很多他们的实验力证。
给你讲讲在个体身上。
这个系统一和系统二是怎么运作的。
会让我们发生什么样的。
有意思的反直觉的事情。
然后因为这本书
其实这里边很多的名词还有很多的观点。
如果大家经常会刷社交媒体。
应该已经看到了非常多的关于这个戏部的解释。
比如说什么毛病效应了。
小数定例
然后包括什么损失业务。
规划名物
这些大家应该当个的概念都能看到。
所以我就不展开讲了。
我就给大家提取一些和我们切实生活。
特别相关的有意思的小例子。
就它会影响到我们生活的。
给大家拎出来讲几个。
第二部分里边讲的。
刚才新光讲这个所谓叫起发法。
它起发法翻译字一个词。
叫Heuristic。
它这个词源好像从希腊词引进过来的。
它就是说我们的思考里边。
有一些捷径
有一些下意识的东西。
它和我们中文里边的起发不太一样。
我们中文里边的起发。
它有点像点燃
它是个正向意引
但是在这个里边
有点像系统二的事。
对
但实际上是系统一。
在这个系统一里边。
其实就是你要下意识本能的做一些连接。
而且这个连接基本上经常是胡联系的。
就大家可以这么理解。
这里边它讲了几个挺有意思的势力。
一个叫小数定律
这个小数定律它是从一个例子开始的。
这个例子是来自于一个调查报告。
这个调查报告在调查。
某一个地方的渗癌发病率的调查。
渗癌发病率调查
它会发现说
这个渗癌发病率高的。
是一个农村人口特别少的地方。
然后大家就会自动开始联想了。
说那肯定是这个发病率低。
是不是因为这个乡村空气清新。
人们生活健康
所以这个发病率就低。
你看这我们经常会做的这些推论。
结果你再看这个调查报告说。
这个渗癌发病率高的地区是什么？
结果一发现也是一个人口少的乡村。
这不就是自相矛盾了吗？
后来你会发现为什么是这样的。
其实合理的解释是。
因为这个地方人口极数小。
我们就是容易在这个小数量的样本里边。
发生极端的事件
这是最科学的解释。
其实真实的原因只有这样。
和这个地方的空气环境没有任何关系。
但是我们在现实生活中就会抽象。
你看我们的大脑系统一。
就会强行做一些英国解释。
就会走捷径
对 就是做一些英国解释说。
你看是因为这个地方的人环境是这样。
所以他这个发病率高或低。
但其实这只是一个随机事件。
他举了一个类似的例子。
就是说你去拿一个瓶子。
一个瓶子里边装了100个球。
这个100个球里边可能有8个是红的。
然后同时你在找一个瓶子里边。
可能只有10个球。
这个10个球里边可能有一个。
或者两个是红的
你就会发现你从那个小瓶子里边。
只有10个球的瓶子里边去炒。
虽然这两个瓶子拿出红色的概率。
基本上差不多
可能我基本上差不多。
但你会发现从那10个里边往出拿。
他拿出红色的可能性就是更高。
因为就那么点东西。
所以这个就要小数定力。
可是理性分析来说。
只是因为你的样本量少。
你就极容易发生这种极端的个例。
但是人们就会忽视小样本量这个前提。
因此我们就会把小样本量里边的实验结果。
进行一些因果联系的解释。
以为我们得到了一个什么样的真相和定理。
其实并没有关系
这个叫小数定律
其实我们大多数的事情你会发现。
他就是没有什么可解释。
他就是随机
比如说我们经常去医院的时候。
我们老问大夫说
为什么怎么就我容易得这个病呢？
医生其实他给你解释不出来。
就是大体上如果真的是从科学。
或者纯理性或者纯经济人的角度。
你会发现这就是个随机。
没有什么原因
教主那段子就是有这样的兵骨。
对
但就是我们的系统1。
他不接受这个解释。
为什么呢？
因为你说他这个随机性事件。
他没有规律
他是个不确定的
所以系统1他就非常厌弃。
这种不确定性和无规律可询。
所以他就是倾向于。
是不是有一个逻辑。
是不是有一条因果链条。
以后我可以按照这个东西去思索。
或者规避就可以得出一个什么样的东西。
因为它更简单
这就和我们之前读那个多巴案联系上了。
对吧？
我们讲那个贪婪的多巴案也是。
他特别喜欢开创一个模式。
找一条路径
因为这个路开辟起来。
大家以后就都在这个路上做住。
下意识的反应就行。
而不用去调取这个系统2的。
这些复杂的思考了。
这个就是要小说定律。
然后第二个和我们相关的。
就是矛盾效应
大家应该也会看到。
他也举一个例子
一个实验
就是大家去问他的学生们。
给两道题
第一个是问你说
甘地去世时候的岁数是大于140。
还是小于140
然后第二个问题是。
甘地去世的时候
他是多少岁去世的。
这两个问题连起来。
你就会发现产生特别有意思的现象。
就大家选第一个题肯定能选对。
因为说140
大多数人都不可活到140。
对
所以你知道大多数人肯定能选说。
他是低于140
但是他什么时候去世的。
当把这两个题放在一起的时候。
你会发现大家去世的年龄。
就倾向于顺着140往下找。
这就是个矛盾效益。
这就是应用在我们生活当中。
就是这样的
他举了好几个例子。
比如说在营销时候常用一个手段。
他们会发现限量和限定购物。
对人的影响特别大。
比如说有一个罐头公司做促销。
说美人限定购买12罐。
不能超过12罐
你会发现大家就会买7罐8罐。
其实你是真的需要7罐8罐没有。
这就是我们经常会在营销中使用的一个手法。
就是当你但凡设定了一个矛盾的目标。
你好像就被操控了。
你就觉得我虽然在做决策。
可是我的这个决策。
就会离这个矛盾的点。
这个上下差异不大。
就会被锁定在那了。
然后寻着这个矛盾效应。
就会给我们提出一个思考。
就是比如说谈判的过程当中。
或者在讨价还价的过程中。
你觉得这东西卖家要卖你10块。
你说能不能便宜点。
卖8块
你觉得你获得了这个农汇了。
但其实这东西一开始可能只有3块。
你就会被矛盾住了。
那什么是聪明的办法呢？
就是当对方说这个东西要10块的时候。
你就愤怒离席
先不跟他谈了
回来拿一个吧？
转一圈之后重新来设置这个系统。
就先摧毁这个矛盾效应。
这就让我想起了
不是这两天这个美伊谈判。
不是说美国内多少个专家团。
也是中间愤然离席走了。
我说这让我想到这个矛盾效应。
是不是也是一种
出招了
我是一种破坏矛盾效应的办法。
这个是矛盾方法
还有一个关键词叫可得性启乏。
这也是一个很有翻译枪的这么一个名词。
这个avulability。
其实啥意思呢？
就是说脑海中
我们想起一个事情的容易程度。
这个就叫可得性
这里边主要讲的就是。
其实我们很容易受到一些。
其他的影响
举了一个例子
就是媒体报道的影响说。
有一个地方发生了龙卷风了。
然后其实我们去正常算这个概率。
你会发现一个人
死于这种极端事件的可能性。
非常非常小
但是一个地方
一旦发生过龙卷风之后。
一个人很长时间以来。
一直会受到困扰
甚至说你走到那个地方。
就会想起说
妈呀这个地方刮起龙卷风。
会不会把我卷走
是为什么？
因为龙卷风这个是个非常戏剧化的。
非常容易被我们识别和记忆的。
这么一个印象
而且在那段时间
媒体就倾向于报道这种。
非常具有戏剧性的。
很小概率的事件
然后一段时间集中渲染。
你的大脑就记住了。
但其实这种可能性非常非常小。
但是我们人就常常在做决策和判断的时候。
容易被这个东西误导。
就常见的
就比如说
有一个地方刚刚发现一个恶性的。
比如说飞机坠机事故。
然后你就会发现
接下来很长时间
人们在选择交通工具出行的时候。
就考虑说我不坐飞机。
但是如果你把航空空谈的这个比率。
拉一个线性的数据出来。
真正从统计学的角度去看。
你会发现
发生空谈的可能性非常非常小。
比你骑自行车遇到事故。
或者我们驾车出门遇到事故的概率。
低非常非常多
这就叫所谓叫可得性启发的这种操控。
还会被系统一操控。
你就会经常对于这种不常发生事件的。
这种规避
这个就是叫可得性启发。
然后后边还有一个叫典型性。
其实典型性用我们自己话讲。
就是刻板印象对人的影响。
这里边也举了两个例子。
就是对人的职业生涯的判断。
这就回到我前面讲说。
为什么他要做这个实验。
这边举了两个例子。
一个是一个大学生。
说这个大学生刚刚毕业的时候选专业。
他们在测试当中列了一堆数据。
说你们来想想这个大学生刚毕业。
他最有可能去选哪个专业。
然后底下呢？
列了一堆这个关于这个人的特质。
比如说他很会做数学体验。
他生性非常的内向。
他不太爱跟人打交道。
巴拉列了一堆前置。
然后你就会发现
大家给他的9个可能选择专业排名。
就会把计算机这些学科靠前。
但是实际上更科学的。
或者更理性的做法。
应该是你把那一年入学的大学生。
选择所有的专业
你都要列一个数据。
就是同年龄段的那一年。
或者在那几年里边。
年轻人更爱选那个专业。
这个可能才是更有可能性的。
更趋于判断队的
可是大家就会根据他的性格。
根据什么来判断
为什么其实就是
这个课版印象也是系统一。
你会发现比如说
他的生性是什么样。
他的性格是什么样。
和他可能选择什么？
在理论上其实并无相关联。
或者这并不是一个更科学的。
更经济的选择
可是大家人们就会习惯于做。
这样类似的勾联
为什么？
他说我们系统一喜欢。
更生动的故事
因为这样你才能讲。
这才能有故事性
所以这个男孩有这样的特质。
所以他上了这个专业。
他的未来会怎么怎么样。
他是一个故事
但是你说这个概率。
说因为那年毕业的大学生里边。
90%都选择了考公务员这个专业。
所以他也选择考公务员。
这就不是一个生动的故事了。
没劲
没意思
这就是解释了为什么说很多人。
明明知道概率是这样的。
或者数据是这样的。
可是还要做出这种和直觉不符的判断。
这里边还举了个挺有意思的例子。
是一个银行职员也是让选。
说你们猜银行职员。
这个女孩叫Linda。
下面对她的描述哪个更正确。
这里边有两个选项很简单。
一个说他是一个银行的职员。
第二个是他是一个女权主义的银行职员。
因为这里边还有对他有一些描述说。
大学的时候毕业于那个大学。
他会参加这个社团活动。
参加一些女性主义的活动遮难。
其实你用科学的角度来讲。
说或者从数学的角度来讲。
这两个选项
他是个银行职员和。
他是一个什么样的银行职员。
这两个是自己的关系包含和被包含的关系。
那你选他是银行职员概率更大。
你选对的可能性更大。
但是大家就是看了前面一系列描述之后。
就选了那个他是一个什么什么样的银行职员。
就选后一种
这还是那个原理
因为你选后一种之后。
大家就会觉得这有很多戏剧性和故事性。
就会做这个选择
像一个老街你转弯似的。
这就是解释他一开始做这个实验的初中。
说为什么你看着这些教授。
这些专业的学生
受过了这么多数学和统计学的训练。
可是他们好像对这些数据完全不敏感。
就像我刚才讲的那个。
这是包含和被包含的关系。
你肯定选包含的范围大。
这里边的概率更大。
可是大家为什么对这东西视而不见。
那刚才这一系列的理论发现。
你会发现其实是系统一在作祟。
让大家忽视了那个枯燥的数字。
毫无波澜的数字
大家就会选这些更有故事。
更有情节张力的这种选项。
这就是大概第二部分。
一些挺有意思的理论。
然后到第三部分
开始讲说过度自信。
这个为什么叫过度自信。
就是我们前面讲说。
这个系统一和系统二。
系统一有这么多问题。
那之所以有两个系统。
就是希望系统一出了bug之后。
系统二出来弥补
然后这个时候大家就问了说。
你看系统一有这么多漏洞。
这系统二咋老不动呢？
它咋老不来弥补呢？
它到底什么时候动。
为什么？
这里边就会发现
除了像清光说的这个系统二。
本身它耗能它费劲。
所以它不愿意动之外。
还有一个原因就是。
这个系统一它会骗系统二。
怎么跟骗系统二
这就要过度自信
它就会把很多系统一出的bug。
它用一套画术或者用一个逻辑。
给它包装起来
告诉系统二说
没事
咱们发生这个问题。
是有理由的有原因的。
没事就跟我们跟领导说。
汇报工作的时候
你会发现说
我们为什么增长率这么低呢？
就是会说
是别人增长率也很低。
所以我们也低
或者说
行业不行
大环境不行
还有就是说
我们已经把增长率低。
这个问题
我们也反思过了
下一季度会更高
你会发现这些解释。
其实并不能真实的来。
产视它为什么低
这都不是原因
只是编出来一个看似合理的。
这么一个联系而已。
这就是第三部分跟我们讲的。
就是系统一是怎么互动。
系统二的
我给大家解释
它有几种方法
一个叫叙视妙误
就是我们特别习惯于事后聪明。
事后大聪明
就是事后诸葛
比如说我们经常会看。
机场里边那种
成功学的叙视书
说它一开始上来久了。
意思说谷歌
我们会发
为什么谷歌这家公司能成功。
其实你从概率上讲。
或者你去各种分析。
它其实只是幸运
它就是个孤立
它这个很有可能
让这个公司再来一遍。
它也不可能成功
但是人们就是习惯于归因。
给它弄一套叙视
新凑一个故事
让它产生可预测的错觉。
但其实这就是一个随机事件。
偶尔就是发生了
那只能证明
它比别人更幸运
其他的什么也证明不了。
但是如何让人获得幸运这件事。
它是不可复制的
不可预测的
所以大家倾向于
就不接受这样的答案。
就只是希望说
你给我来一点
我能用得着
我能复制的东西
这就叫虚实谬误
还有一个叫有效性错觉。
这个特别有意思
我看到的时候值乐。
这个有效性错觉
它的势力就是
这个作者本身
他去见了非常多的。
华尔街的金融大横。
而且是有一家证券。
股票公司邀请他来的。
说你看看我们这些分析师。
怎么回事
他们是不是能有一个什么模型。
就这些业绩好的分析师。
是不是能有一个模型。
让他们业绩更好
结果他分析了非常多的。
分析师的各种的履历。
包括各种投资的成果。
或者反正各种数据。
弄了一六购
发现他们其实
这就是个随机性事件。
发现那些高薪的经理的。
悬股水平
长期以来
根本没有那种随机选的更好。
就是有理论和没理论的瞎选。
其实赢的概率也差不多。
然后他就把这个结果。
报告给了这些基金经理的领导们。
领导看完之后
就是表面上不致可否。
那大概是这样的吧？
可是也嘴上不承认。
然后这个作者自己还写。
说他们肯定把我这报告。
看完之后就扔了
绝对不会对外公布。
为什么呢？
其实他们自己也心知肚明。
我这些选的也都是。
就能中或者不能中。
其实也是随机的
他说但是
如果我们接受这个设定。
那谁来找我们选股呢？
对吧？
所以我们还是倾向于。
我们认为自己是有预测能力的。
这些是有逻辑的
我们更倾向于这套叙事。
所以就要有效性错觉。
然后最后一个叫规划秘误。
规划秘误里边也讲了。
一个特别有意思的例子。
就是讲这个作者本人的。
讲这个卡尼曼本人。
他说他当时在大学里边。
组织了一个课题
弄了一个小组
决定新开一门课
这个开课的过程当中。
他是发他们的研究也很顺利。
进展也很顺利
然后就号召学生说这样吧？
咱们为这个课
得专门写一本教材。
大家觉得这个教材。
咱们多长时间之内能写完。
每一个学生都写了个小纸条。
说我觉得咱们两年。
肯定能写出来这本教材。
后来呢？
卡尼曼自己还说
两年是不是太激进了。
咱们再宽松宽松
咱们就预估两年半。
能写出来吧？
后来他们把这个预测时间。
放在这两年半
然后拿这个时间去问了。
他的一个同伴
这个同伴就所谓叫第三视角。
他问这个问题很科学。
他说过去有多少
像我们这样的小组。
他们进展怎么样
他们写这个教材
大概用了多长时间。
然后呢会发现说
首先就像你们这样的科研小组。
能有最后有结果的比率。
只有40%
也就是60%这些小组中途。
解散了
都散了
都解散了
就没有研究
无疾而终
没有任何研究成果。
首先成功率只有40%。
另外说
这些过去的人里边。
写出这个所谓教材的时间。
平均的时间是七年以上。
没有七年的
然后他就卡尼曼就继续问。
那你看我们这个小组的水平。
在你过去见的这些小组里边。
处于一个什么位置呢？
然后他同伴说
低于平均水平
都熬不到你40%。
这是毫不留情面
对 它是低于40%。
但是卡尼曼就说
按照我的这种背景。
对吧？
我研究了这么多
我这个时候更正确的方式。
我就该关闭这个项目。
因为成功率第一
大概率大家得写七年。
然后我们这个水平还不如人家平均的水平。
你就知道这件事成功。
就别干了呗
非常非常渺茫
可是他们没有这么选择。
他们老觉得说我可能是个例外。
万一我不是呢？
对
然后就努力
他说他们最后耗时了8年。
8年多吧？
才把这个事情弄完。
而且他当时已经不在这个小组了。
基本上和大概是一样的。
而且等他们编完这个之后。
这个课程或者这个研究。
也不再被那么推崇了。
所以这个教材致使之中。
也没有被运用
基本上就是用8年时间。
研究了一个没用的东西。
他就以这个例子为开始。
就是你会发现公司里边。
或者我们很多组织里边。
都在做这样的事情。
就是你明明知道
正确的成功的概率非常小。
为什么还会坚持做。
这个东西就是我们所谓叫沉默沉本。
大厂里边各种那个项目组跑马。
就是咱看了
这个概率咱这个赛道能不能跑出来。
咱先都试一试
然后打一干的再说。
完全不看概率
然后他还举了一个例子。
就是说悉尼歌剧院的建造。
说当时预计的这个歌剧院。
1963年就完工了。
大概耗子700万就适应了。
结果最后1973年才完工。
最后耗子1.02个亿。
他说这就是我们经常会常见的一些事情。
投入到一半
你要选择是关闭它。
close掉我们接受现在的损失。
还是说我们可能会好。
没事坚持做
然后你会发现大概率很多人。
明明知道这件事成功率很小。
还是选择了坚持下去。
为什么这也是因为系统一。
我们当时刚做的时候。
你处于这个项目前期的时候。
你有巨大的热情
而且你之所以做这个预测。
是因为你当时一切进展的都很好。
所以我们不可能对。
将来还未发生的事情。
有任何的绝差和绝之。
你都没有概念会遇到什么？
因此我们就想不到那种。
可能发生的糟糕的情况。
这里边其实肯尼曼也想说。
就是关于预测这件事。
其实他就是很难的。
尤其是对将来的预测。
你不知道你参考的系数。
该是什么？
你参考的维度是什么？
我们只能通过这些非常有限的信息。
而且这个有限的信息。
我们参考的这些信源。
很有可能大概率
就是刚才星光讲的那些。
跟情感相关的
跟个人耗物和情绪相关的这些东西。
而我们经常会忽略。
那些冷冰冰的没有故事性的数据。
其实最好的科学的做法。
就是你去找一个
跟这个非常相似的案例。
你去看看一样的工程。
在一样的条件之下。
大家资质都相同的情况之下。
那个做了多少时间。
用了多少预算
出现了什么问题
然后我们在不停的对照和教验。
然后才有可能出现一个比较合理的预测。
但是大多数人都不会选择这个。
为什么？
因为这个很复杂
而且里边的参数会很多。
这个内庭
对
大家就倾向于拍脑来选那第一个的。
所以第三部分大概讲了。
就是那些部分二里边。
那些微小的认知偏差。
累积起来之后
就会形成一种全举性的傲慢。
然后说如果是这样的话。
我们还有没有可能糾偏。
就看一看
给了一个听起来非常不sexy的解法。
就是你要靠这种大样本量。
把它放在大组织里边来做决策。
因为这才会有这种军职和回归。
比如说我一个人做的决策。
可能就没有我们三个人做的决策。
看起来更理性
就可能我一个人一上头说。
行吧咱们一天读三本书。
是这个时候可能星光说。
不行不行
大医说
哎呀？
那可能更慢吧？
就在一个大组织里边。
可能这个决策的合理性。
会相对更好一些
好
那超哥给我们分享了。
第二第三部分里面。
非常有意思的一些理论。
以及运作机制
那接下来我们请大老师。
给我们讲讲这本书的。
最后两部分
第四第五部分
他到底讲了些啥
那第四部分就是
我前面说的前景理论。
他的这本书的核心部分。
有很多实验和统计。
如果是大家感兴趣。
可以看看书
我选几个比较有意思的概念。
讲一讲
首先前景理论刚才说了。
他是用来解释
人在面对不确定的情况下。
怎么做决策的这么一个理论。
然后具体怎么说
就是当我们面临一个。
稳赚的情况下的时候。
人们会倾向于这样好就收。
面临稳赔的时候
人往往会变得更加激进。
所以这就会导致很多金融投资。
日常消费
或者你的行为习惯。
或者公共政策
在出现了很多不合理的行为。
就是当我们看到说。
面临稳赔的时候
或者说有风险的时候。
理性人应该是回撤的。
但是往往人会更激进。
那首先他们评估了一个结果。
就是看一个人的收益赚多少钱。
其实不是看他的最终财富总量。
而是人们会倾向于。
看他相对于某个参考点的变量。
这怎么说呢？
传统经济学里面
我们会认为说同样的钱。
给不同的人
带来的快乐应该是一样的。
因为钱数是一样的。
但是这就忽略了人的心理状态。
会带来的影响
如果要更准确
卡尼曼说我们就得引入某个参考点。
这个就是卡尼曼提出的一个核心理论。
就是参考依赖点这个例子。
比如我们拿年中奖举例子。
文化有限
今年年中再要给
星光和超哥发年中奖。
先说如果
如果是他俩在年中奖。
都拿到了5万块钱的奖金。
这个时候他俩的幸福感会一样吗？
还真不一定一样
如果按照传统经济学。
我们会说
咱俩人得的钱一样。
幸福感应该相同
不对
这个时候要引入一个所谓参考点。
才来判断星光和超哥的幸福程度。
比如我先跟超哥说。
超哥的参考点是
年初我小川跟超哥说了。
说你看咱这个今年波克元年。
又没远起来
行业喊冬了
都不行
估计咱这一年得白干。
年中奖最多也就发个。
1万块钱
然后这个是跟超哥这边。
然后我又跟星光说。
你看咱今年这业务不错。
业绩挺好的
走起来了
元年远起来了
咱这各方面表现都挺好。
估计年底咱能有个8万块钱的奖金。
这是跟星光这边说。
这时候两个人的参考点就不一样了。
但是看结果
最终年中奖一看
发了个5万块钱
每个人都是5万
这个时候虽然两个人账户里的钱。
都多了5万块钱
但是星光肯定比超哥更不高兴。
或者换句话说
幸福值肯定是超哥高与星光。
因为星光感受到的是损失。
他会觉得少了
被苛刻了
产生一些挫败感
但是超哥感受到的是收益。
他会觉得你之前跟我说的1万块钱。
现在给5万
多了
所以他俩在这个例子里面。
各自的参考点就变成了。
预期的8万和担心的1万。
最后得到了5万块钱。
两个人的参考点是不一样的。
这个就是参考依赖点。
在我们评价一个人的幸福指数。
或者是心理状态时候产生的波动。
预期
对
他讲核心观点
就是为了说明人的神经系统。
我们的大脑是很难接受绝对值的。
其实绝对值对我们来说很困难。
就你不知道它对你意味着什么？
你必须放在某个体系里面。
对
得有比较
会对变化值更敏感。
好
接下来就产生了一个进一步的一个概念。
叫做损失厌恶
这个肯定很多朋友都已经非常熟悉了。
就是人们对于同样数额的收益和损失。
损失带来的心理痛苦。
远大于收益带来的快乐程度。
对
这个跟前面说的参考依赖点的例子。
逻辑是相通的
就是星光为什么会觉得没有超哥那么高兴。
因为在星光的大脑里面。
它映射出来的是
我少了3万
我亏了3万
因为那个参考点是8万。
对吧？
它得到的是
原来说说好的8万。
少了3万
但是在超哥的大脑里面。
他得到的信息是我多了4万。
因为之前的参考点是1万多了4万。
所以一个是损失
一个是收益
甚至我们可以预测。
说在发年中奖的那一天。
星光是不高兴的
因为他的幸福只是负的。
超哥是开心的
幸福只是正的
好
那接下来我们就要看。
这所谓的损失厌恶物。
和获得幸福感的那个幸福值。
到底差距是多少
这个我以前没想过。
以前我只知道
就是人都是倾向于损失厌恶物。
你说说好的给我
后来不给我
但是你给我一少的我也不高兴。
这个叫损失厌恶物。
那这里面不存在一个什么比例。
卡尼曼在通过大量的实验。
像什么抛硬币实验。
后来他发现
就是面临同样数额的收益和损失。
那个损失带来的心理痛苦的程度。
大概是收益带来快乐程度的多少倍。
大概是1.5到2.5倍。
你得通过超过损失前数的1.5或者2.5倍。
你才能弥补回来
那个快乐和痛苦值。
他实验是怎么做的呢？
他说如果抛硬币
正面你输100美元。
那问反面你赢多少钱。
才愿意参加这场比赛。
我们一般人往往给出的答案。
肯定不是100美元。
你肯定要高于100。
就是亏的钱和我赚的钱。
我得大于这100。
我才能愿意参加这比赛。
我们现在想一想
如果是挣100和赔100。
你是不是更不想参加这个游戏。
结论也是同样的
就是大多数人的答案会在200美元左右。
所以他得出一个结论。
就是说这需要我们一般是。
两倍的潜在收益
来抵消一倍的潜在损失带来的恐惧。
所以有了1.5到2.5倍这么一个数据。
当然这也是一个平均值。
也有很多人的
这种损失厌恶的程度比他人更强。
你看我比如可能就是。
就是我就是损失厌恶程度更强。
可能你你给我1000块钱。
我才愿意抛一次
好
那为什么会有这样的心理状态呢？
就是在进化心理学里面。
我们会倾向认为
大脑里处理威胁的这个部位。
比如说性质盒之类的。
它的反应速度极快。
它会首先激活我们DNA里面。
那个趋利避害的机制。
尤其是避害
因为在原始环境里面。
所谓的威胁
损失的优先级
会远远高于收益和机会。
我们举个例子
就是原始人
原始人都没有什么经济学概念。
一些原始人
你错过了一顿好吃的烤肉。
就是部落里面烧肉了。
就是你没改上
这算收益
那你顶多就是禅一顿。
或者是饿一顿
犯不上特别大的损失。
但是如果你忽视了一个潜在的。
纽约使者
比如外面有个狼
你没看见
带来的损失
可能会意味着死亡。
所以就在这么一条进化的路线上面。
就是因为我们的祖先。
都是足够损失厌恶物。
因为不然才能活下来。
才能活下来的这些人。
就导致我们现在的人类的基因。
就是一定是损失厌恶。
高于收益的那个享受的。
我们就是被这么传下来的。
否则就灭亡了
刻在基因里边了属于。
对
是被基因延续下来。
今天人就是这么个模式。
写死了
好
那么就是损失厌恶。
会怎么影响我们在不确定环境里面。
做决策呢？
它提出两个概念
一个叫做现状偏见。
什么意思
就是因为我们是厌恶损失的。
所以通过改变现状。
可能带来的损失
在心理层面
我们会被放大
我们会更强调说
现状改变了
我会失去什么？
潜在的收益
会在心理层面被缩小。
所以这会让人们更倾向于。
维持现状
不做出改变
这其实是非理性的。
这个叫做现状偏见。
第二个损失厌恶带来的影响。
就是非理性的
会带来一些贸易壁垒。
就是在谈判的过程当中。
刚才潮哥说的
这个每一谈判
所谓谈判什么意思。
谈判就是双方各自让步。
达到一个妥协的结果。
对吧？
但是在这个过程当中。
损失厌恶就起作用了。
因为不管哪一方
他们做出来的让步。
都会被团队
会被这个组织看作是某种损失。
然后由于是损失的厌恶。
双方都会觉得
让自己的让步更沉重。
更不愿意达成
所以导致谈判谈不下去。
或者说
所有人都会认为
谈判是一件艰难的事。
这就源于双方
都处于损失厌恶的情绪里面。
接下来这本书就提到了一个。
行为经济学里面的核心概念。
叫做秉赋效应
这个也是
2017年的诺贝尔经济学奖。
里查德·赛勒提出来的一个概念。
他简单就说
当一个人拥有了某样东西之后。
那么他对这个东西的估值。
就会显著高于
他没有这件东西时候的估值。
比如说拿星光那堆手办举例子。
当星光买一个手办的时候。
可能这手办200块钱。
但是在他家放了三年之后。
你再让他卖
他肯定卖的是高于200的。
尽管这个东西
可能就放在柜子里。
都没拆封 都没动。
好 那为什么会有这么一个心理状态。
也是一个著名的实验。
叫做马克杯实验
这个是丹尼尔·卡尼曼。
他们和赛勒一起设计的。
他们实验设计什么呢？
随机给一部分受试者。
发了一个印着一个笑灰的马克杯。
这个马克杯大概市场上卖6块钱。
6美元
然后告诉这些受试者说。
好 现在这个杯子是属于你的了。
给你了
这是一部分受试者。
另一部分受试者是没有杯子的。
好 接下来让这两部分人开始交易。
他们研究者让有杯子的人。
就是这个卖方
你出价你可以提出标价。
你出多少钱卖出这个杯子。
然后让没有杯子的这个买方。
出价买杯子
实验结果就证明了。
说双方的平均要价是多少钱。
刚才我说这个市场定价是6块。
卖方的平均要价是7.12美元。
7.12
然后买方平均出价是2.87。
对 不到3块钱
这个都跟这个市场定价的6美元。
如果我们认为6美元是一个最理性的定价。
因为是拿这个买的。
市场定价
跟6美元产生了极大的偏差。
好
是的
而且关键的就是同样一个杯子。
仅仅因为拥有权的不同。
所以你看这个两方的定价。
卖方心中认定的价值。
竟然是买方的两倍还多。
这就证明了我们人是有多么的不理性。
而且这还是一个实验。
这个是一个实验
就是这杯子我刚给你。
对吧？
就是刚刚放你手上。
还不像星光那手办。
在家里真的放了两年了。
放了三年了
或者从小就喜欢
那你这个人对这个东西的定价。
就是截然不同的了。
好
这个就是说禀负效应。
就是我会赋予一个东西。
什么样的价值
那禀负效应跟前面说的损失业务。
也相关还涉及到一个新的心理学的概念。
叫做所有权偏见
所有权偏见包括损失业务。
现在我们就能够理解了。
就是对于卖方来说。
卖出杯子被大脑定义为一种失去。
一种我没有了
我损失了一个杯子。
好
那对于买方来说
买杯子被定义为一种获得。
所以因为刚才我们前面说的损失业务。
就是大脑和偏向于损失带来的痛苦。
大于获得带来的快乐。
所以卖方必须要卖出更高的价格。
来补偿抵消这种痛苦。
刚才我说的那种痛苦。
大概倍数在1.5到2.5之间。
这也就大概能理解了。
为什么大家的定价。
也从7块1毛2和2块8毛7。
都跟6美元产生了一些偏差。
对吧？
对
那所有权偏见是什么意思。
就是我们人
倾向于把我们拥有的物品。
看作自我的一部分。
放弃它这个东西
在心理上
不仅是你失去了一个成本。
一个金钱的东西
更像是失去了一部分自我。
再加上这东西
万一是你从小就喜欢那。
我从小就喜欢青龙猪。
你非把我这苏武空给买走。
好
那我赋予它的价值。
我要出价的时候就更不理性了。
更高
对
那这种不理性
其实在市场里面是会阻碍你的交易的。
因为你可能会让一个东西。
本来在它市场行情最好的时候。
你有可能卖出去
但是你又因为你的贫富效应。
或者说你对它的估值过高。
会导致它卖不出去制销。
那它就会贬值
这个在我们说传统的经济学里面。
它是一个不理性的决定。
对
大老师说到这
我想起来看这部分。
有一个例子还挺切切的。
如果大家是炒股的朋友。
应该能有同感
就是说一样的是
你比如说急需缺钱的时候。
你需要卖出两个股票。
在这个书里边
他举了一个例子
就是说一个男士
他要为女儿筹备婚礼。
他筹备婚礼的时候。
就需要紧急用一笔钱。
他有A和B两只股票。
A股票是他已经卖出之后。
他确定自己挣了
B股票是在赔钱
他说其实如果按照经济学。
更理性的是说
我要卖掉那只赔钱的。
因为你就知道它的业绩会不好。
现在它表现不好
你应该把表现不好的卖掉。
但是大多数人一定会卖A股票。
因为卖A股票之后。
我就挣着钱了
不亏了
但是卖B股票
大家就一直觉得说他不行。
他还在损失
我不能卖出去
因为我现在卖出去就承认。
我一定是有既定的确定的损失了。
所以你看在我们日常生活里面。
刚才超哥说的卖股票是一个。
还可以举几个例子。
就是我们可以自我检验一下。
我们是不是在商家设计的消费陷阱里面。
其中有一个就是适用期营销。
就是很多商家会提供说。
30天无理由退货。
这个东西
如果你是一个产品拿回家使用之后。
你发现
我好像没那么喜欢或者我没那么需要。
我们还拿手办举例子。
比如星光又买了一个特别好的手办。
钢铁侠放在家里
放了一段时间发现。
我没地方放了
这个一一要英雄床站定了。
我得把这个东西腾出来。
这个时候
你虽然
你并没有消耗这个东西。
但是这个时候如果再退货。
心理上会觉得我损失了一个东西。
因为那30天已经跟你产生连接了。
你会觉得我拥有它了。
这个跟钱没有任何关系。
它只要放在你家
你就会觉得这是我的东西。
我要把它退走的时候。
那个心理成本会更高。
所以这种30天使用期也是一种营销手段。
它当然会保证一些消费者的权益。
就是我实在不想要。
我可以退掉
但是很多人会因为这个30天。
视为一种损失
然后大大降低了退货概率。
还有一个营销上的问题。
就是很多人会对虚拟资产产生一些束缚。
这可能打游戏的很多朋友就知道。
就比如说游戏里的皮肤。
那么现实道具
就这些东西
一旦你拥有过
你在这个角色身上穿过了。
你用过了
你就会对它的估值更高。
你就很难放手
也会降低退货概率。
会让商家赚得更多。
当然更多的时候是我们自己忘了。
就是我忘了有这个东西。
我忘了30天了
说到这如果各位听节目的朋友。
想到了什么类似的心理消费的陷阱。
也可以在评论区跟我们说一说。
有些是你动茶出来的。
大家一起逼逼坑
好
然后第四部分还有一张。
我觉得比较有意思。
简单跟大家分享一下。
就是罕见事件这一张。
刚才超哥也说了
就是龙卷风举这些例子。
就是卡尼曼会认为说。
人们在面对罕见事件的时候。
对这类事件的认知。
会表现得非常的不稳定不理性。
为什么？
书里这么写
卡尼曼说他自己也不能免俗。
他说有一段时间
以色列的公交车上经常发生自杀式的炸弹袭击。
而那个时间我正好在那里。
当然从绝对意义上说。
这是极其罕见的事件。
01年12月到04年9月。
以色列共发生了23起爆炸事件。
造成236人死亡。
当时以色列公交车每天的乘客量约为130万。
好
这对旅行者来说风险非常小。
但是公众并不会这么认为。
就是我们的系统一也不会这么认为。
人们尽可能的避免乘坐公交车。
车上的乘客也焦虑的环顾林坐。
寻找有可能藏有炸药包的包裹。
或者是宽松的衣服。
我租的辆车
做公交车的机会不多。
但我傲闹的发现自己的行为也受到了影响。
比如
我发现我不喜欢在红灯的时候停在公交车旁边。
绿灯亮起的时候
我使力的速度会比平时更快。
我为自己感到羞愧。
因为我更了解风险。
我知道他小到可以忽略不计。
也知道对我行为的任何影响。
都会赋予我极小概率事件过高的决策权重。
事实上相比停在公交车附近。
我在车祸中受伤的可能性可能更大。
因为它开的快
但我避免公交车
并非出于理性的生存考量。
而是来自于当时的体验。
就是停在公交车旁边。
会让我想到炸弹
这些想法令人不开心。
我避开公交车是因为我想思考别的事。
这个就是卡尼曼
他即便是自己作为一个心理学家。
作为一个经济学的研究者。
他也不能免俗地做出这样的选择。
他自己也反思
所以我们经常会认为某些事件。
尤其是罕见事件
比如车祸 恐怖袭击。
包括重彩票 升职加薪这些。
我们都会倾向认为。
它发生的概率比实际要大。
这个就是人脑会产生那种过高估计。
还有一个概念叫做过高全横。
就是即便我们知道。
刚才上面说的这些事情的发生概率都极低。
但是我们仍然在做决策的时候。
会给它分配更多的心理权重。
会因为它而改变我们的行为模式。
总会想着万一呢？
就是这种万一是刻在我们人类DNA里边的。
你很难克服的一种心理状态。
好 那接下来的问题它就继续研究说。
那为什么会有这种。
就是我们为什么会给罕见事件那么大的权重呢？
就跟这本书提出来的系统有关系。
系统一
系统一会不自觉地帮我们塑造出一种。
它叫做生动性
因为系统一是非常擅长于。
促进这种形象思维的。
当我们想到比如中奖。
生殖加薪或者说空难。
或者一些灾祸的时候。
脑子里会出现那个非常鲜活的画面。
比如领奖的欢呼
飞机的残骸
然后这种生动性会让我们产生了一种。
叫做认知放松
让我们觉得这件事情是可能发生的。
只要画面足够清晰。
那概率的大小就不再重要。
就是系统一越强大。
系统二就越不会动。
而且这种画面我们又是经常会在。
各种电视电影文艺作品里看到的。
就是所有的我们看到什么？
好莱坞大片
或者是一些成功学。
都会告诉你最后怎么着。
怎么一个大爆炸
或者是我最后生殖加薪怎么样。
我财富自由
这些都会不断强化我们系统一。
被使用的概率
然后这也就解释了。
就是为什么恐怖主义。
能够通过极少数的攻击。
就在全社会全世界范围内。
制造出远超于实际的危险的焦虑。
就是它激活了全球人的系统一。
就是这么一个道理。
那怎么办
卡尼曼建议
就是在面对罕见事件的时候。
我们需要强迫系统二进入。
用统计数字去对冲那个生动的想象。
不要问说这件事如果发生了会怎么样。
而是要换一个问题。
就是说这件事
在过去的一万次里面发生过多少次。
当我们想这个的时候。
你就会把自己系统二激活。
然后通过数字去扭一下自己的直觉。
这个就是大概我觉得。
第四部分
还有很多东西非常有趣。
我就先拎出来这几个概念。
跟大家分享一下
前经理论
然后还有我们为什么会对小概率事件。
这么的在意
好
那接下来就是第五部分。
最后一部分这就比较短了。
第五部分就是提出来。
我们认知生命的有两种方式。
是通过两种自我来实现的。
一个是体验自我
一个是记忆自我
刚才我说体验自我非常当下。
它是你感受每一分钟的自我。
它负责回答的问题就是。
我现在怎么样
比如说我现在正在录音。
我坐在一个办公椅上。
我腰有点酸
嘴有点干
然后刚喝了一口咖啡有点烫嘴。
或者说我能感受到咖啡的香气。
或者是突然在公司群里面。
收到领导一个at。
你紧张了一下
大礼拜二上午的找我干嘛？
这种都是体验自我负责的部分。
然后这种感受是连续的是实实的。
但是它没有决策权。
就是它不参与你接下来做的任何的决策。
而且非常容易被遗忘。
就是你说现在是礼拜二上午11点11。
礼拜一上午的9点25你在干嘛？
其实你想不到
但是那个当时9点25的感受一定是车。
肯定是发生过的
你可能在地铁上挤着呢？
或者什么的
你仔细想一下才能想到那个感受。
这是极其容易遗忘的。
这是这个体验自我。
另一个叫做记忆自我。
它是负责记录评价和讲故事的自我。
它负责回答的问题就是。
总体来说过去那件事怎么样。
它来负责做决策
它甚至说是决策的独裁者吧？
比如说我们是不是愿意重复一次旅行。
是不是会反复的想念一个人。
这都是那个记忆自我在决策。
好
那既然记忆自我在做决策。
它的决策逻辑又是什么呢？
我们是怎么通过记忆选择。
接下来要做什么呢？
卡尼曼就发现说
这个记忆自我它也并不准确。
它会遗忘很多东西。
有点像我们做波克尔。
一个比较糙的一个粗简圆。
就大概给你拼凑拼凑得了。
它评估过去有遵循两个原则。
也都是做实验得出来的结果。
可惜这些原则都是非理性的。
什么原则
第一个叫做封中定律。
封是那个封值的封。
中是终点的封
叫封中定律
它说我们评价过去经历的。
一段整体的记忆
怎么评价
评价标准主要是通过这段经历。
里面那个最高峰
或者说最强烈的感受。
和这件事情结束时候的感受。
来决定了
我们可以回想一下。
比如说你评价一下。
你过去的某一段感情。
或者说过去整个世界。
经历过的一种情绪。
或者是我某一次开会。
或者某一次录节目。
你可能考虑的都是。
在这个过程当中
最顶峰的
可能是最高兴
也可能是最不高兴。
也可能是最压抑
也可能是最恐惧
它是某种封值情绪。
和这件事情结束时候给你带来的。
誓然了
一旦吧？
总算过去了
希望它还有
就是通过这两个时刻的东西。
来决定你评估过去的原则。
这个叫做封中定律。
然后另一个叫做时长忽视。
就是时间长度
会经常被我们忽视掉。
就是只要这一段体验。
这个封值和结尾的感受相同。
那么在这一段体验里面的痛苦或者快乐。
不管它是持续了五分钟还是五分钟。
这种感觉在记忆自我的评价体系里面。
几乎没什么区别
就是我们会自动忽略掉那个持续的时间。
好 那就这两种自我的区分。
也影响或者改变了。
说我们看待幸福的标准。
会影响我们做关于生活的种种决策。
那体验自我
评价幸福的标准
就是我现在的快乐或者痛苦程度怎么样。
我现在腰有多酸
嘴有多干
脑子有多发木
这个是现在
关注的是我当下的情绪。
感官日常的这些比较索随的事情。
记忆自我评价的标准。
就是说
我对自己的现状生活满意吗？
我想要的目标
我想达到的收入
我的社会地位
达到了没有我想要的那个。
我的公司直级
有没有达到
我说三年一条槽
或者三年一长的水平。
有没有达到
但是这两种标准
往往会让我们有一种幸福的分裂感。
就是一个人可能在日常生活里面。
每天感觉到压力都很大。
体验到的都是那种不快乐。
但是在被问到
你幸福吗的时候
我们往往会因为
我有一份看起来
凭体面的工作
我的收入还不错
那我的社会地位还不错。
我的公司直级还不错。
会被这种记忆自我满足。
也许这乍一看上去没什么问题。
就是当代人不都这样。
就是这种幸福的分裂感。
我觉得也是同样的。
就是你问他具体的时候。
他会觉得
我今儿开这会闹心死了。
我每天写周报很烦。
但是你说你幸福吗？
大家可能答案会不一样。
那这里面就隐含着一种风险。
或者一种矛盾
就是我开头节目说的。
就是我们到底是活当下。
还是活记忆
我们会不会因为
过于关注对幸福的记忆而忽视了当下。
就是我们的系统一和系统二。
到底在怎么运作
想象一下
比如说
我为了这个书里面写。
想象一下
我为了在社交媒体上。
发一组完美的度假照片。
忍受了长途飞行的疲劳。
景点的拥挤
还有昂贵而难吃的饭菜。
那我的体验自我在那几天里面。
大部分时间其实是很疲惫的。
很痛苦的
但是因为照片很美。
或者说照片点赞很多。
照片真的去到了
我想去的那个打卡的位置。
给我的记忆自我提供了素材。
我可能会真的觉得这趟旅行很值。
好
那如果一个人的生活。
完全被记忆自我接管。
那它会产生什么？
它会不会陷入一种。
成就成隐的问题
就是它不断追求更高的职位。
更完美的家庭标准。
因为这些在叙述者的视角。
叙述中听起来很棒。
但是这个人可能会忽视掉了。
就是他的生命的每一分钟。
自己到底是什么感受。
就是我为了追求那些。
我付出了多少
如果一个国家的GDP很高。
人们的社会地位和成就感很强。
那个记忆自我很满意。
但是与此同时每一个人。
都因为竞争过度而每天焦虑。
因为各种卷失眠
各种痛苦
那这个社会真的幸福吗？
这个可能就是
大家都会去思考的一个问题。
对
好
所以就这本书里面说。
无论何时人们的心情。
都取决于自身性格和整体幸福感。
但情绪幸福在一天和一周中。
也会有很大波动
当下的心情主要取决于当前的情景。
例如影响总体工作满意的程度。
比如福利啊职位啊？
这些一般不会影响工作情绪。
情境因素更重要
比如说跟同事交往的机会。
工作里的噪声时间压力。
这些都是负面情绪的重要来源。
以及老板在场
那注意力是关键
情绪状态在很大程度上取决于。
我们关注的事情
我们通常专注于当下的活动和环境。
不过也有例外
主观体验的质量有反复出现的想法。
而不是当前的事件决定。
当坠入爱河的时候。
即便是堵车我们也很开心。
悲伤的时候
即便是看搞笑的电影。
我们也会闷闷不乐。
但在正常情况下
如果我们专注于当下。
苦乐便会从中产生。
比如要享受吃的快乐。
你必须意识到自己在品尝食物。
我们发现
法国女性和美国女性。
在近时上花费的时间大致相同。
但法国女性近时时的专注力。
是美国女性的两倍。
美国人近时时通常会做其他事情。
从中获得的快乐也就相应的减少了。
我也在想
当我们在吃一顿所谓的漂亮饭的时候。
你只一边吃
享受这个食物本身。
还是一边吃一边再刷到底。
特责了多少个赞
你吃到那口热或者没有。
那它继续说
这种观察结果
对每个人和社会都有意义。
如何利用时间是人生中可控的事情之一。
很少有人能通过意志力。
让自己拥有快乐的性情。
但有些人会安排好自己的生活。
他们减少通勤时间。
花更多的时间与喜欢的人。
一起做喜欢的事
还有他说
这句话我最喜欢
他说
除了健康
对当天情绪最好的预测因素是。
受访者是否与亲朋好友联系过。
可以略微夸张地说。
幸福是与你爱的人和爱你的人。
共度时光的感受
看到这儿我会觉得。
这本书还是一个心里一家写的。
是一个温情的东西。
然后每一张号码不都有一个。
我觉得像小抄部分的一个小金句。
对小抄部分
他这个部分的小抄。
就是说
提升幸福感最简单的方法。
就是掌控你的时间。
你能将更多时间用于喜欢的事吗？
他提出了一个问题。
这就是第四部分和第五部分。
我们三个人分工
把这本书里面的五个部分。
里面特别重要的概念。
以及特别有意思的运行机制。
给大家做了一个书里。
如果你也看过这本书。
你觉得我们刚才有哪一条没有提到的。
你觉得特别有意思的。
你也可以在评论区给大家讲讲。
分享分享
你觉得特别对你有启发的。
那最后一个问题
就是聊聊
读完这本书以后
对我们实际生活有什么启发。
在你的生活当中
你和这些书里面提到的概念。
理论
建立了哪些实际的连接。
对你的生活有什么指导没有。
超哥先来聊聊
我看完这本书
首先其实对我启发挺大的。
是我在前面分享
那个卡尼曼本身的。
他写出这本书的过程。
对我启发还挺大的。
就是我们前面屡次提到。
他并不是一个经济学专业的研究者。
然后他因为做了一个研究碰巧。
获得了那样的成就。
这就让我想到了
其实我们人做很多事的时候。
虽然我们前面这个书里边讲的内容。
可能听起来有点没那么积极。
你会发现
我们苦心故意
或者说我们特别精打细算的。
想要做什么事情
结果你会发现你的这些目的。
或者你的这些动机根本敌不过。
你系统一里边那些本能。
让你觉得好像自己自我很失控。
但是我觉得卡尼曼本身的例子。
挺给我启发的
就是他是出一种直觉。
或者出于一种自己对身边的。
具体问题的好奇
展开了一个研究
他先开始
可是他并没有给自己设计一个预知。
或者具体的目标说。
我一定要实现什么？
他只是先开始
然后开始的时候
他可能是从A地点开始。
但是他最后从一个完全没有意想到的。
路径上获得了肯定。
或者收获到了某种成果。
我觉得这是我看完这本书。
给我一个挺大的疗愈。
因为我们很容易看完这本书之后。
我那我这也控制不了。
那也抵挡不了
我能怎么办
后来我看完这个
卡尼曼本身自己的世纪。
让我明白了说
是不是可能有一个结法。
就是说我们先积极的先开始。
乐观的开始
然后对终局保持谨慎。
甚至保持悲观
我们先不要去想那个未来。
然后留意向大老师前面讲的。
我们要留意过程当中的体验。
然后随时较真过程。
然后有可能会在意想不到的结果上。
取得成功
然后因为你一开始没有设想到。
我的结局会是什么？
所以无论结局能有一点什么？
它其实对我们来说都是意外之喜。
都是那个
你无意当中得到的奖赏。
那可能整个人的幸福指数。
或者幸福程度就会更高一点。
否则的话
一旦你涉及了特别死的目标。
只要没有达到或者有一点点偏差。
对你来说都会激活那个所谓叫厌恶损失。
或者叫激活你的损失厌恶。
因为我没到那
差一点都没到
即便很近也是没到。
我依然会有非常大的挫败和非常大的难过。
所以我觉得卡尼曼这个事。
就给我们了一个挺好的启示。
就是以前我不知道。
我跟乌鸦做的搭档。
我们乌鸦就老说一句话。
说我们要Say Yes to Everything。
他就觉得他是一个挺悲观的人。
因为他老想设计
他会发现我这个事。
好像在我大脑边运算。
运算无法实现结果。
我就No 我就Say No。
后来他说我先不管这个结果。
我就先Say Yes to Everything。
有可能大多数事情做一半就舌了。
但也没关系
但凡这里边有一两件事。
本来从A出发
做人又生出来B又生出来DF。
可能就对我来说是一个收获。
我觉得这个卡尼曼的这个世纪。
或者他自己的人生经历。
就给了一个挺好的验证。
然后第二个是
因为我们这期节目上线的时候。
又是4月了
4月又到了读书绝。
就一年一度的
来到了强调读书很重要的日子。
就是我自己在读这本书的过程当中。
我屡次内心当中有一些感慨。
就是感慨就是还好。
我看了这本书的整本书。
因为其实说实话
这本书不是一个陌生的书籍。
就是但凡大家翻开了这种知识类的内容。
或者知识类的短视频。
你一定会发现这本书。
被大概率的高频的提及。
它里边无论是我和大老师。
我们仨是在过程中讲的一些名词。
什么锚定效应啊？
什么这些损失业务。
一定是被大家高频的提及过。
然后用一到两分钟时间。
给你讲讲这到底是个什么东西。
可是直到我看了整本书之后。
我才第一次意识到这本书。
它是只在解决什么问题。
就是它整体来说
并不是和那些片面的一两个概念和观点。
想要表达的东西
其实有的时候甚至是大乡进亭。
当我们不断的去听这些概念。
或者观点的时候
你的应用场景是什么？
大家想想
无非就是可能你用这个概念和观点。
在某一次闲谈当中。
给大家讲一下
或者跟大家分享一下这个知识。
可能所有人听完就完了。
甚至你可能自己听完就滑过去了。
可是经过读这个书籍。
我们留下的是什么？
我其实对这里边了很多概念。
我到现在也很模棱两可。
尤其让大老师讲的那部分。
有很多我也没弄清楚。
但是对我个人来说。
阅读这本书给我留下了什么？
第一
我其实学到了很多。
研究一件事情的方法。
你看它是怎么在设计实验的。
比如说很多我们觉得无法测量的事情。
比如说你到底怎么测量一个人的幸福。
你到底怎么来测量这个人。
在当下是快乐的还是迷惘的。
我们老觉得这是一个非常抽象的。
但是卡尼尔用他自己的实际研究。
你会发现可能测量兴奋的时候。
是观察同距同孔的变化。
测量幸福的他用了一个什么指标。
用这个处于这个
这虽然可能这东西。
我们一辈子不做专业学术研究。
都用不着
但是我觉得他给我提供了一个思考。
就是有些东西
他就是你要去找有专业的人。
他是可测量的
一切都是CS的
就是他是给你在其他的。
还是那个在意外之外。
会给你一些东西
另外一点
就是他收获的都是那些和核心知识点。
无关的一些起发
可能未来
我虽然现在不做市场营销了。
但是如果我还做市场营销。
可能里边提到的有一些东西。
他会对我有帮助的。
可是这些都不是那些。
常常被提及的
最关键的核心的信息。
我觉得这对我来说。
就是让我再一次知道了。
读书这件事的意义和价值。
其实读书这件事也是。
他就是一个不断的。
调取你系统二的一个过程。
我们就整个读的过程中。
还挺痛苦的
对吧？
你们俩应该也是
因为里边有大量
我们不常接触到的概念。
有数字
还有计算
你那概率还得看半天。
对
可是虽然这书里面没写。
但是我在想说
你怎么才能让我们。
这个系统二的部分。
没有那么懒惰
就是你得老用老用。
就是要接触这些不快的。
让你感觉到不适的。
割灯的
让你觉得我得停下来的东西。
常常的调取一下
可能我们这个系统二。
才能没那么懒
我自己的设想
所以这就是
又说回来读书的意义。
还是挺
推荐大家去翻一下这本书的。
而不只是局限于那些。
可以跟别人称作谈字的那些小概念。
那些小概念
记得再多
反正我个人觉得
对我也没什么帮助和没什么？
因为我这辈子可能也不会用它。
除了跟咱们俩讲完这个节目之后。
我就可能给它丢弃掉了。
但是在看在过程中看书的这些体验。
我的那些感觉
我觉得就留下来了。
甚至超哥说
我觉得整本书就是一个。
不断调用系统二的过程。
读书就是这样的
看完这本书
我想到一些日常消费过程当中。
我们要怎么能够避免系统一。
帮助我们瞎做决策。
就是不那么理性的过程。
就前面说的几个
比如说
我们在买这种高价产品的时候。
我们要看到那个锚钉效应。
是怎么发挥作用的。
我们应该问自己
就是调动系统二
就是强迫系统二进入。
比如我们看一个东西。
原价可能两万块钱的镜头。
现在只卖14999的时候。
我们那个系统一会立即告诉我们说。
那我赚了5000。
对
我少花5000
我赚5000
但是防御机制是什么样的呢？
我们会强制系统二进入。
就是遮住那个原价。
问自己
如果这个东西上市那天就卖14999。
我没见过那个
你还会觉得它的性价比高吗？
我们换一个问题
我们不要让那个系统一的直觉。
那5000块钱阻止我们做决定。
如果是的话
你还觉得性价比高。
那你买它或者你去消费这些东西。
是没有问题的
但如果你的答案产生了怀疑。
你就可以再问一问自己。
那我是不是被刚才那个5000块钱。
那个定价和打折价给忽悠了。
然后刚才还有超哥说的。
就各种限定
很多什么限量款
是不是都有这样的问题。
然后这个是那个毛定效应的那个警惕。
然后还有那个就是。
两个自我的带来的购买动机消费时候的不一样。
就是我们到底是在为哪一个自我买单。
我们是在为体验自我买单。
去买了一个比如舒适的床垫。
一个人体工学的椅子。
一个高刷的屏幕
还是一个好喝的咖啡。
这些东西
它的确是服务这个体验自我的部分。
你买的是真实的每一分钟的感官的质量。
然后那如果是为记忆自我买单。
我们会发现
我买了一个可能是很昂贵的。
但是并不好玩的打卡的门票。
然后排了很长时间的队。
到了那出了一个千篇一律的照片。
那我买的这个东西。
我花的这个时间成本。
到底是为了什么？
就是我是仅仅为了拍照而买的装饰品。
花的时间和精力
还是说我真的是享受整个旅行的过程。
是为那个不要被记忆自我所绑架。
所以那个决策的建议就是。
在我们购买大型物品之前问问自己。
我是在优化我未来的体验。
真实的体验
还是在我未来的叙述素材上面积累东西。
只是为了说我买了这个之后。
我都已经想好朋友圈怎么发了。
那往往这个时候
我们可能要警惕一下。
是不是那个记忆自我又被调动出来了。
所以我觉得看完整本书。
就是系统一的冲动和系统二的懒惰。
这个东西它是写在DNA里面。
是我们非常难以克服的。
但是我们可以通过。
就像锻炼肌肉一样。
尽量把系统二拿出来遛流。
就是让它都出来走两步。
可能走两步它又回去了没关系。
但是你意识到我是脑子里。
会有两套不同的角色系统。
这件事我觉得就已经非常有价值了。
敢让自己慢下来
你会发现慢能解决一切事情。
当你想买东西之后当下先别付款。
可能当下你先没有想清楚。
但是你先别付
先别让一发生作用。
就有可能给二机会。
我想起来一个事
最近不是我在北京改家庭摇号吗？
排号我跟星光还老聊这个事。
那天我就跟我爸妈说这个事。
我说按咱家庭积分。
比如我摇了10年那个号没摇上。
但是现在如果新的积分出来。
我可能够资格买一个电车。
然后我就跟他俩说。
我跟霹雳也没想好。
要不要买那种平时车用的也不多。
然后我担心的是什么？
就是别又跟回头那游车似的。
这号没用过两天作废了。
我要再想用的时候。
它那个可能资格没有。
我又得租号或者我又得摇好一年。
会不会回头政策又变。
我就被这种问题所困扰。
就觉得好像会亏
如果我不用这个号就亏了损失厌务了。
然后我爸我估计他也没看过思考课。
但是他就在前面跟我说。
你现在就想如果这个号现在不限量。
谁都能想买车就有牌。
你还会去买车吗？
会不会
不会
就是你会
是吧？
所以我爸好像帮我激活了一下系统二。
就是我说确实也不会。
那我为啥还要买
我到底是在为什么而买单呢？
但是我也现在也没做这个决定。
那分还没出
所以不断的调试自己。
你看看还是爸爸们会用系统二。
我觉得跟生活当中的联系非常紧密。
有很多看完这本书之后。
意识到在生活当中有很多愚蠢的认知偏差。
这就是会出现在自己的身上。
那也是卡尼曼说的。
这本书的终极目标是让你更了解自己如何犯错。
不是让你变得更理性。
而是让你更聪明的对待自己的非理性。
就是当你出现非理性的时候。
你怎么办
他其实是想揭示这个。
那直到当我们知道了这两种系统。
系统一和系统二
以及由此而产生的各种认知偏差的原理之后。
我们怎么样去应对它。
我觉得就是卡尼曼在书里面也说了。
就是刻意的可能需要你去调动系统二。
或者刻意的需要去在系统一用直觉的方式。
做出决策的时候
去更多的起到监督和修正的作用。
比如他在书里面提到更好的认识自己。
然后也要觉察自己。
就是说让自己少犯系统一带来的错误。
就是因为我们说系统一和系统二之所以。
构建成现在我们人类的这个样子。
它既有来自于原始时期。
我们从那个时期开始。
对于生存概率最大化。
延续下来的很多习惯。
同时我们也知道
因为系统二它是懒惰的。
它是耗能的
所以我们要在调动它的时候。
需要更多的给自己一些提醒和警惕。
当系统一出现一些可能会。
产生认知偏差的情况的时候。
系统二要及时的调动起来。
及时的被唤醒
不能老让它在那儿。
当一个锁屏或者当一个屏宝。
永远唤不行
那你系统二就废了。
所以让它更能和系统一形成配合。
两个系统互相之间打配合。
就能更好地指导我们的想法和行为。
整个这个书看完之后。
我就突然联想起了和现在特别火的。
AI的这些大模型之间的一个。
特别有意思的事
就是什么呢？
那天我看了一个文章。
写的AI大模型
它经常会犯一些人类不会犯的低级错误。
然后想起来也特别有意思。
这个里边其实就涉及到。
今天我们这本书里面的。
有关人类思考的模式。
系统一和系统二的差别。
就是外国有研究机构做过这个研究。
它是当成学术研究来做的。
就是它给各种各样的模型。
大模型提问题
然后有一个问题特别逗。
在网上也是形成了一个梗。
叫起车不带车起头不带头。
就是你问大模型说我想洗车。
我们家距离洗车店只有50米。
请问你推荐我走路去还是开车去。
外国的学术机构
他做了研究他会发现。
53个主流的模型做系统性的测试。
单次调用的情况下。
只有11个模型答对了这要题。
就是翻车率超过了80%。
大模型都会给你个答案是什么样的答案。
他会跟你说走着去。
对他会跟你说只有50米。
那当然就走着去了对吧？
要不你开车去还得废油。
对你开车去还得开回来。
还得开去
等你开回来了万一遇上下雨了。
不是白洗了吗？
他给你出了一大套特别符合逻辑的答案。
但是他这个问题就在于。
他忽视了前提
就是你是需要去洗车的。
你不带车去这个问题就不成立。
同样的洗头不带头也是同样的问题。
就是他说你问AI说我想去理个法。
但是最近很累头很大。
你说我要不要带头去。
然后大部分AI
对我们不小说嘛你这事。
大部分AI都会说那不带头。
洗头不带头
除了这两个看似脑筋转弯的问题之外。
这个机构也给他们提了很多。
更加学出性的问题。
比如说里边有设计到语义的。
有设计到目标函数的等等的。
他研究出了之后
他会发现一个结论是说。
这些人类的大模型看似。
我们现在用的什么？
Deep Sake啊Kimi啊Chart GBT。
他们都有深度思考模式。
然后你提一个问题的时候。
他会给你回答逻辑特别严密的一整套。
然后甚至于有些你想不到的点。
他都能想到
我们会倾向于认为。
他好像是在用慢思考。
用系统二的方式
来给你做问题的回答。
但实际上研究发现。
他回答你问题的方式。
还是系统一的方式。
就是大模型也在用系统一的。
直觉式的思考方式。
来回答你所提出的问题。
为什么？
你比如说刚才洗车不带车的那个事。
就是因为它里面出现了。
卡尼曼这本书里面所提到的。
叫启发式或者叫触发或者叫结净。
这个结净是怎么搭乘的呢？
是你告诉他说
洗车店离我家只有50米。
对吧？
然后50米的这个距离的如此之近。
就成为了AI大模型思考这个问题。
最先考虑到的那个结净。
对
他就不会想到说
我原来是要去洗车。
我的目标函数是洗车。
不是去要到那个目标。
他把目标的近和到达目标本身。
形成了这个所谓的启发式和结净。
于是他说
那你就走着去
你洗车去反而增加成本。
然后为此还给你出了一大套。
看似逻辑非常严密的论证。
所以这也就是说
现在的AI看似好像是。
用深度思考的方式在回答问题。
其实他和你怎么给他提问。
以及他怎么去从语异当中。
去找你这个提问里面的。
思考模式是有非常强的关系的。
所以这也就是为什么？
把卡尼曼的这个人类的思维。
快思考和慢思考
我们去考察AI
其实也是一个全新的对照方式。
就是人有两套思维系统。
我们认为AI可能跟我们的思维方式不同。
但实际上你会发现好像也挺相似的。
就是大模型也被困在了一个快思考的模式当中。
他长篇大论的去给你分析利弊。
但是其实底层的决策机制。
仍然是我们说触发式的。
结净式的或者叫起发式的。
所以很多时候我们说AI幻觉就这么来的。
好像你觉得AI他给你长篇输出的。
这个长篇大论像那么回事。
但是其实你仔细去考察。
你会发现他是有幻觉的。
他是有错误的
他的那个调理清晰。
错词得体论据充分的背后。
实际上是有很多人类经验。
我们靠我们的直觉能够判断出来的。
但是大模型没有这个直觉。
我们说洗车你不带车那叫洗车。
人类一下子就能通过我们的系统一判断出来。
但是大模型不行
大模型不知道说洗车跟带车之间。
是有非常强的关系的。
他比那个距离50米要有更强的判断力。
要有更强的前置条件。
不是大模型不通过这个来判断。
所以当我们知道卡尼曼的这本思考快语曼。
里面提出的很多思维模式之后。
我们可以放在今天应用在我们。
随处可见的AI上面。
我们也能够看到很多的应用方式。
就是我们去考察AI的幻觉。
我们去看AI给我们出的答案。
到底对不对的时候。
我们也要去警惕
可能他也在用快思考的方式。
在回答我们那些看似慢思考的答案。
我看完这本书之后突然联想起了。
然后AI的这个事。
我觉得真的是挺有意思。
也挺有道理的
我帮AI这个名
刚才你说的时候我问了一下。
Jeff奶他们应该进步了。
现在进步了
我问的是我家距离洗车店有50米。
我现在要去洗车
要不要开车去
这个是那个问题对吧？
对
然后他给我的回答是。
由于距离只有50米。
建议步行前往或先于洗车店确认。
他有一个前置的那个。
他说从距离角度讲。
50米通常步行不到一分钟。
开车可能还没出车库。
还没有完全掉头就已经到达。
如果洗车店目前有位置。
可以直接洗手动
将车开过去是合理的。
但如果需要排队
建议先不行
然后接下来他说什么距离极短。
频繁发动车辆进行极短的距离移动。
可能会增加发动机机碳的风险。
水温还未上升
是他讲的很多
对
所以这个也告诉我们。
就是当我们现在当下。
很多时候需要去跟AI交互的时候。
我们再给他提问
或者说我们在跟他交流的时候。
我们考虑到他也许跟我们人一样。
也有系统一系统二的犯错的可能性。
那你在跟他打交道的时候。
你在跟他提问的时候。
也许会更完善
也许会规避掉他很多可能。
出现幻觉的可能
就像我们在生活当中提高警惕。
也许会规避掉很多我们。
认知偏差的可能
行
那今天我们关于斯卡·夸尔曼。
丹尼尔卡尼曼的这本经典的唱销书。
经典的科普著作
就先聊到这
如果你有任何想要跟这本书。
想要跟我们分享的。
以及这本书对你的启发。
这本书在你的生活当中是否帮助到你了。
你怎么去对待你的系统一和系统二。
怎么让他们两个更好的配合。
有什么好的方法
好的方式
好的建议
都可以在评论机构里留言。
我们会从评论区选出五位朋友。
送上思考快语慢的直书各一本。
好
那今天我们就先跟大家聊到这。
祝你在生活当中
不管是用快思考
还是用慢思考
都能够有更多的正确的决策。
让你的生活更幸福。
那我们下期再见
拜拜